but i don't think that we could wait for
russia to take over ukraine and then
maybe start encroaching into poland and
then at that point like oh [ __ ] maybe
now we need to do something because then
we're gonna be back at ground zero for
this conversation and instead we're
gonna be having a panel in you know four
years saying like well should the united
states support poland on the ground and
it's like well if we put troops there
like that's pretty aggressive and i
don't know like just because they took
over poland like are they really gonna
go even further you know like it's only
like georgia or crimea ukraine like is
it you know in summer poland like i feel
like you kind of have to draw a line in
the sand pretty early so that the rest
of the world knows where you stand i i
just said kevin did you just say you're
not worried about putin uh
shooting nuclears at the united states
is that what you just said hold on hold
on i said if the us puts troops can you
just say that didn't you just question
it
i'd like to welcome you all to the
hippie dippy round table this will be
the 53rd episode on youtube and i'd like
to thank you all for taking time out of
your busy fridays to join us we have a
lot of new guests and exciting guests so
we're going to jump right into it with
introduction before going through the
rules alex stein is running a little
late apparently he's never used discord
before and so he's trying to figure that
out on the job today but i'm sure he'll
be here in a bit we're gonna start
in the top left hand corner with adam
something could you introduce
yourself yes so i'm adam uh i like
trains i make videos about
transit and urban planning and also
politics
and the latter is uh why people usually
get mad at me but you know if you don't
like it well get [ __ ] you don't have
to watch yeah that's me happy to have
you here we love it with when uh more
video essays come on different platforms
and like do different types of content
like debate content i love to see that
um now we're gonna throw it over to
christian who i haven't seen since freer
fest so it's good to see you again
christian
you too man me too so i'm christian
watson i'm the host of a
youtube podcast show called pens of
politics which lives on my youtube
channel called christian watson i make
political social and cultural commentary
which is backed up more by a
philosophical viewpoint which
unfortunately is something that is
sorely missing from the discourse today
most folks take talking points and run
with them i try to dig deeper and look
at underlying principles and see how
things connect throughout history and
the world and so i look forward to a
good conversation tonight
okay he's also been featured on the bbc
as well which uh good for you christian
oh yeah and fox news now wonderful throw
it over to destiny who has a lovely
smile
hi i hate the bbc and i hate trains and
urban planning uh my name is destiny um
i am a far left or center-left person
who you talk to and um yeah i look
forward to screaming everybody tonight
wonderful destiny has a long record of
having friendly relationships with
reporters we're going to throw it over
to parker
yo what's up my name is parker uh i run
a tech talk platform you might know me
from the jubilee episode that i was in i
normally just debate on uh tick tock
about like vaccines other topics like
that uh i'm on the left uh if you do
know me but um yeah i'm excited to be
here and excited to debate i saw you
were debating vaccines earlier today is
that uh correct yeah i do that every day
on my blog something about uh kovit
getting on oranges
oh yeah i know uh no some person was
talking like it's just some anti-vaxxer
came in talked about like uh how they
used a pcr test to test it orange and uh
it came back positive so they were like
using that to say that we don't even
know that the virus exists but um yeah
wonderful uh also for could you clarify
which jubilee episode you are you were
on for the viewers i do yeah i was on
i'm sorry i'm just kidding
yeah i was on liberal teens versus
conservative parents if you all do i
want to check that out
wonderful uh gonna throw it over to
pixels pixel
good morning everybody uh my name is
pixel i cover the news at an ungodly
hour for most americans so if you're up
too late and you see me on you're yep
you're up too late um
i am two left for some not left enough
for others and yeah
that's that's about me
i have the news
and i have a great american accent
and everybody's a favorite american
political commentator wonderful now
we're going to throw it over to kevin
castle
thanks dylan it's great to be here uh
i'm kevin castle i'm the host of
superpower broadcasting we stream seven
days a week to twitch and upload content
uh everyday to youtube i'm going to be
getting back into uploading premieres as
well to youtube so be sure to subscribe
on both platforms if you want to keep up
with me i'm also on twitter at kevin
castle and if you'd like to debate me
you can send me a dm over there i like
the baits let's go
wonderful now we're gonna go throw it
over to william howard taft
thank you dylan excellent excellent
throw it over as always
i go by taftaj on the internet you can
call me april if that's easier
i consider myself center-right sort of
odd weird politics but my goal is to
model a version of right-wingedness that
is free of some of the more toxic
elements
that is typically associated with that
without political position
happy to have you and alex stein of the
conspiracy castle will be here
soon he has uh he is famous for a lot of
hits on the internet which i'm sure
he'll talk about soon such as uh being
the person who sung that uh vaccine song
at that city council meeting that was
viral very recently uh i'm very
interested to have him on as well he'll
be on in a bit so we're going to jump on
to the first topic after clarifying some
roles the first rule is we won't do
anything against twitch terms of service
uh obviously a bunch of us are streaming
this on twitch and we would like to keep
our jobs and feed ourselves and i would
hope that you uh have enough interest in
the show that you would like us to keep
our show that's the first world the
second rule is when i'm talking no one
else is talking if it's difficult to
hear me you just turn up the volume i am
not talking to give my opinions uh
everybody knows what my opinions are uh
they're pretty left-wing but i try to
keep them out of moderation duties and
so if i'm talking i'm merely trying to
moderate so please uh try to recognize
my voice before this uh whole thing
starts thirdly we will not be attacking
people's immutable characteristics i
don't care if you're mean my job is not
to moderate you into a nice person or to
give you like some moral character
tonight my only rule is that you do not
go after people's immutable
characteristics sex gender race etc if
you can do that i would greatly
appreciate it um other than that i think
that's most of the rules uh the format
is simple we will have short intros and
outros that are uninterruptable you
don't interrupt other people during
those periods and an open period in
between uh if you find it difficult to
uh deal with this format because i know
having eight people in a room all
wanting to talk is difficult um as a
last resort raise your hand i'll write
your name down and make sure the
conversation eventually gets over to you
but i will let the conversation go
naturally unless i see it get too
disorderly then i will interrupt and i
hold the liberty to mute if it gets too
out of hand it's not personal i just
need to give order i am not an anarchist
i am an authoritarian and you will feel
that wrath today wonderful uh does
everybody understand the rules
any questions
wonderful yep to you understand the
rules or yep do you have questions
yes ah got you okay the first one yes
the first one so you understand the
rules good okay so the first topic uh is
i made it a little broader because we
have some non-americans today
um pixel
and so the question oh and kevin
should
the west help ukraine you can of course
talk about this from an american
perspective or a canadian perspective or
an australian perspective should the
west be helping ukraine at this moment
as tensions continue to rise between
ukraine and russia i will make one
clarification before we start unless the
people clarify before a topic during
their intro segment assume that
everybody here today are not experts on
every given topic and please get
information from other sources this is a
political panel on twitch on the
internet this is not um the people
debating in oxford just make that very
clear for everybody at home we're going
to start in the top left hand corner
with adam something
thank you so for the record i am not
american either i am hungarian
from eastern europe uh the hot spot of
the events
so the question should be should the us
support ukraine uh the answer is yes are
you [ __ ] nuts like it's a slam dunk
both economically and geopolitically uh
ukraine is a nation that fought
essentially civil war uh to align itself
with the west um and so we cannot really
and they petitioned us for help and by
us i mean nato and nato align countries
which we commonly understand as the west
uh after that uh to for us to promise
help and then break that promise and let
them be overrun by russia would be a
huge geopolitical loss for the west
which would lead all kinds of other
um possible concessions or possible
problems down the line so i would say if
we show strength now and help out not
with troops on the ground no one is
discussing troops on the ground but
equipment and uh generally threatening
russia with sanctions so
then that would be
a uh well a good thing essentially the
other argument is of course economical
uh ukraine is a very rich country in
national natural resources they have
significant industries from aviation to
rocketry and they are going to be the
next agricultural superpower because 25
percent of all the world's black soil is
located within ukraine which is like the
best type of soil on the planet having
them inside the
eventually in the european uh trade bloc
will have will lead to essentially lower
food prices and uh all sorts of uh
other benefits and i oppose what russia
is doing and i think you should too
because well i oppose it because i don't
like imperialism
and i support ukraine and i think we
should support ukraine just like how we
should support taiwan against china
i a larger neighbor threatening to
invade the smaller neighbor or you know
that funny german gentleman who thought
that
who essentially invaded german-majority
areas of czech republic back then
i supported the the
smaller country in both cases and
opposed large of them for imperialistic
reasons
and that's my standard
i had no clue you were so old that you
supported czechoslovakia during that
conflict uh yeah that's really a man of
experience
you might be surprised
throwing it over to christian
yeah so a lot of folks might look at
this matter through a geopolitical lens
uh i like to see it as the as the
the sort of philosopher who likes to see
it through a sort of moral lens because
i do think that when we ask ourselves
should someone's do something or support
something we're ultimately asking a
moral question if we're not asking a
moral question then we're not asking a
question that necessarily compels us to
do anything uh but since moral questions
oftentimes include rules and principles
that are binding on people or at least
if they are good moral questions they
will then that's all that'll also be the
dimension that this is approached from
now this is not to say the geopolitical
dimension is not important it most
certainly is important i think that it
is quite important that president biden
has pulled not not quote-unquote
non-essential diplomatic staff from um
ukraine which has made the president of
ukraine quite angry and has made him say
that this is going to cause
diplomatic capital to be eroded i think
that it is quite important that the
american media is now buzzing over war
which has also made the president of
ukraine pretty angry and has and has
called him which has excuse me compelled
him to say to to ask people to moderate
their tones uh and and really a lot of
people in ukraine at least according to
news reports uh seem to be handling
hanging this better excuse me than a lot
of us over in america or even other
parts of the west
because this is quite routine for them
russian aggression is quite routine for
them they understand um how they cook
your crumbles but ultimately the moral
question is this and i'm going to
ultimately should this shift this
question towards america because i don't
think the west as a whole has the same
moral stake in ukraine i think different
countries have different stakes in this
situation um germany for example has a
pipeline that goes throughout there that
russia is obviously very interested in
preserving and that's a very different
moral stake than what america may have
in ukraine um i don't think that the
americans have a moral obligation to
help ukraine really in any way shape or
form
now does this mean that we shouldn't
well it depends in which way would we
since there's a moral obligation this is
a more open-ended question if there was
a moral obligation that mean we would
have the necessity to do so i don't mind
us using our diplomatic authority um to
try to challenge putin's march uh uh
march westward i don't mind us trying to
do that um i do think that sanctions
obviously in a time when inflation is at
a all-time high and a time when supply
chains are disrupted around all around
the world uh sanctions would obviously
not necessarily be an ideal mechanism to
deal with this and fundamentally they're
also not a really moral mechanism to
deal with this as well you cannot
morally morally stop someone from buying
or selling with some another private
party unless they are buying and selling
goods that were stolen or something that
sort um so that's probably not a very
good idea
um but if we want to use diplomatic
authority to challenge putin i have no
problem with that when it gets to
sanctions and even worse when it gets to
troops on the ground that's when i have
a problem
because not only is the moral obligation
not there there are many there are
numerous geopolitical consequences and
diplomatic consequences to such a strong
show of force so that's my opinion on
the matter okay wonderful thank you
christian and we're going to throw it
over to oh one second somebody asked can
you just explain what a conservatarian
is quick like in one sentence oh yeah so
a conservatarian is someone who holds
tradition to be paramount in the
american sense but also believes in the
principle of individual liberty okay
wonderful now we're gonna throw it over
to destiny for uh their intro on the
topic
yes
wonderful i think the united states uh
yeah should probably intervene i think
everything's been said on both sides of
this but uh to echo some of what we said
earlier um i think that we kind of have
the moral right here in terms of
defending um ukraine's right to
self-governance it's also important to
signal to nato and fellow nato
allied countries that we're going to
take a stand if russia decides to expand
aggressively in directions where it
shouldn't um i i think it's a pretty
common sense thing that uh i i don't
think the question is
the interesting question i think is
whether we should support ukraine it's
in what capacity should we support
ukraine because i don't think just
weapons on the ground is anywhere near
enough to overcome russian uh
superiority when it comes to airland or
sea um so the question i think becomes
more like is this like a boots on the
ground type of thing is it an air
support kind of thing or is it just like
some sort of other you know we support
them on ground supplies and then we
sanction russia or withdraw them from
certain international things like swift
or whatever in order to pressure russia
away from doing anything
wonderful uh it seems that a certain uh
person from the conspiracy castle with a
new hit song about vaccines has entered
would you like to introduce yourself and
give a quick intro on uh it's about
ukraine i i assume you i figured
yes yes guys i'm primetime 99 alex stein
i'm on the grind all the time i'm the
host of the conspiracy castle i'm your
conspiracy [ __ ] uh and do i need to
make my statement on ukraine as well oh
would you like to wait a second to
collect your thoughts oh yeah sure i'll
let you wait a second yeah yeah i'll go
yeah yeah yeah thank you sorry for being
late i'm such a boomer i don't know how
to work discord so now now i got to work
in now i'm cooking with gas it's okay
you're on a musical tour you're in the
next ariana grande there you go so i'm
always a little late i'm a diva we're
gonna throw it over to parker
uh so i think what the west should do is
pretty basic here i think that obviously
like what other people have said we
should support through like defensive
weapons and sanctions i think there are
lots of economical things or economic
things that we can do in order to hinder
russia or hinder russia's ability to uh
intervene in ukraine i don't think that
russia's economy could actually sustain
any type of long-term uh war or an event
or intervention against nato and ukraine
um so depending on like what russia does
i think we should determine what to do
based upon that and based upon like what
we have right now i think sanctions and
defensive weapons
would be things in order to mitigate any
harm that could possibly happen but
depending on what they do we should
change uh how we uh intervene
wonderful now i'm going to throw it over
to pixel
um i mostly agree with the other
leftists on this panel um
but to provide some context australia
already is helping ukraine uh i think
they requested cyber security support
and we gave it to them um so that is
already happening kind of at least
around nato allies um there is also i
don't know if you guys know uh that
there are six russian ships currently in
irish waters um intending
to do some sort of like
war that you know demo kind of things
between ships um and there's currently
like a whole bunch of irish fishing
boats out there protesting that um
so just like adding some context because
i generally genuinely agree with um
sovereignty being important but i think
also it's very difficult um from an
outsider perspective to understand what
is going on within ukraine as there has
been so much um
uh different groups of people uh go
through ukraine there's quite like a
rich uh
cultural history but there's also lots
of differing opinions um i think we
should overall support their right to
sovereignty if asked for
um also i do know that some of the
groups that are
pushing back against russia are on the
far right i just think these things are
incredibly complex i don't think that
for me personally i
would ever have enough information to
know exactly what they need um but if it
is asked for by a democratic government
i think that the west should probably
intervene
okay now i'm going to throw it over to
kevin castle
uh thanks dylan yeah so basically as far
as the situation in ukraine is concerned
i think that we obviously need to set
some uh terms to define right at the
start so when you talk about the
potential invasion by russia in ukraine
what we kind of uh imply in that without
necessarily thinking about it is that
we're accepting as status quo their
existing invasion has already conducted
and so uh russia invaded ukraine in 2014
and has actually as a matter of fact
occupied the crimean peninsula and are
still occupying it they've even placed
troops and everything in there they
forced them as basically to be a part of
their country they as well have forces
in donetsk and lukansk
what they call people's republics nova
russia whatever uh it's basically
occupied russian territory like what
they did in georgia in 2008 occupying
south ossetia and abkhazia this is a
basically a repeat of that but on a
larger scale so when we talk about a
potential invasion we should clarify
what we're talking about is is putin
going to expand his existing invasion
his existing uh occupation into a
further incursion uh i think it really
depends on our response uh proactively
if we're going to see a broader war
there uh so putin has put upwards of 175
000 troops on the border in in the
border areas and he's got about twenty
thousand forces in uh donetsk and
lagonske areas so we're talking about
potentially up to two hundred thousand
though it could be as low as 120 000. uh
that's a significant force the entire
ukrainian army numbers about uh 220 000
or so so we're talking about a
significant capacity from a nuclear
power uh to intimidate ukraine into
submission basically now people will say
they'll talk about well
uh basically the us made some promise to
gorbachev at the tail end of the soviet
union it should be clear that that was
never actually formalized it was never
an agreed upon treaty or anything not to
expand nato as well uh of course none of
those leaders are in charge today putin
wasn't there and biden wasn't there and
of course the ukrainians weren't there
polls weren't there etc
this ultimately does break down to the
myth of consensual sex meme that you'll
see which is like oh well ukraine can
sense nato consents and then putin's
like isn't there somebody you forgot to
ask re you know getting triggered and
everything and so uh he has no business
in ukraine he's already there
unfortunately nobody's arguing to go in
and get crimea back that territory's
lost now but if we're going to learn our
lesson i mean unless you're was boppin i
think he's probably the only one
advocating for literally invading russia
but what we need to do is we need to
learn our lesson here and what we need
to say is uh we're not going to repeat
2014 we need to actually send troops
over there as a as the west to stand up
for the sovereign right of ukraine to
exist as a sovereign country at 44
million people
canada has already put upwards of 400
troops there which is twice of the
united states i mean i think it's very
unfortunate for all my criticisms of
justin trudeau it's it's very clear that
he's actually uh you know one-upped uh
joe biden on this i think it's
embarrassing to see joe biden be so
effectless in the face of russian
fascism and russian imperialism and my
hope here is that we do not repeat uh
the same mistakes of uh barack obama and
neville chamberlain and essentially
appease and encourage russia to go in
the irony is that if we don't send
troops there to deter war there will be
a war thank you okay
and taft
this is a great point best point i've
heard all day
should the us help ukraine of course i
think a lot of people can agree that
some help should be rendered unless
you're a giant fan of russia and just
want russia to expand forever
but what we disagree about is what that
help should look like we've seen the
effects of a series of disastrous
foreign wars and it's time for america
to stop
america is this world power spanning the
width of a continent bordered on either
side by oceans and friendly neighbors
the north and south
america can afford to
involve herself less in the constant
state of others
what we've created over
the past you know 40 years is this
global security network
with of temporary peace treaties the
kind of things that will disintegrate
without the us continuing to bear the
burden of maintenance forever we've also
seen the continued
you know ruin of states um
which we were hoping to create you know
turn into good liberal democracies and
allies we've seen the preservation of
states that we vowed as sworn enemies
we've seen the disastrous effects of
going to war in the middle east we've
also seen how effective it can be when
we actually go to the negotiating table
and try the tact of diplomacy so should
we send arms to ukraine yeah probably we
should make it difficult for russia to
invade but as far as engaging in war
ourselves absolutely not we can
engage in economic sanctions sure help
ukraine yes war no
okay and we're gonna wrap it up with
alex stein for intros
wow what a pleasure okay guys i mean
basically when it comes down to ukraine
you just gotta look at this zelinski guy
he was literally an actor on a tv show
that played some sort of like
anti-league guy and then he gets put and
then he actually
creates a political party
based on the tv show that he was an
actor in so these people take their
political uh spectrum so serious they're
so they want such good leaders that they
think it's so cool the people of ukraine
think it's so goofy and funny it would
be like if we got brendan frazier why
don't we make brendan frazier uh the the
president because he was on tarzan so
this linsky character is crooked as a
dog's hind legs we know that i mean he's
a he's an actor he's a tv actor we know
the misdoings with biden and ukraine
with uh hunter biden's misdealings with
ukrainian with ukraine so we know that
they have some sort of evidence against
the united states and that is the
leverage that they're using for us to
even waste our time on the border we got
a border with a bunch of child sex
trafficking and let me tell you
something we got guatemalans we got
hondurans coming here by the minute on
the border i'm in dallas texas and
you're talking about the ukrainian
border now that's that just shows you
we're not based in reality people don't
have common sense you're trying to pump
up the military industrial complex let
me tell you something about the military
industrial complex the amount of money
that we spend on that on on on the
system that is the military industrial
complex could fix homelessness could
give us a universal health care so all
the stuff that people on the left that
y'all want socialism which i'm not
against i'm not against some sort of
social services but if we could
reallocate our finances instead of going
to the ukrainian border and maybe fixing
our border then our world wouldn't be
such a bad place because we shouldn't
have to be here arguing over oh we
should go help the ukrainians against
russia they both suck any or any eastern
european country is going to be ran by
idiots and we know that because zelinski
was like i said an actor on a tv show he
might be a good guy i'm not even judging
his character i'd like to act i've been
an ozark of bottled water commercial i
drank it i looked good i was the star of
the show i know what it's like to be an
actor i know what that's like i noted
what it's like to get caught up in that
and then he uses that he parlays that
into a presidential campaign i'm not
even trying to hate on that but at the
end of the day these are the people that
are running the ukraine the country of
ukraine so if their people are this
there's this this is how deaf they are
oh look at the tv
fix our country and then when russia
comes in now you gotta get joe biden
sleepy joe biden's gotta come in there
and somehow clean up the mess yeah right
i don't have time for that i got messes
on my border i'm in dallas every day i
walk around bachmann lake park i see
guatemalans get off a bus in a backpack
wandering around don't know what to do
i'm not saying that's bad i'm not
anti-immigration what are you talking
about i love it i mean i wouldn't i'm
just still i'm just saying that's a
problem we can fix that problem and not
worry about the ukrainian border so
that's where i stand with that
thank you
i appreciate that thank you
uh for everybody once again i would like
you to all remember the rules uh stein
you were told the rules by danabo am i
correct wonderful yes okay just wanna
make sure not to repeat them okay uh do
try to keep it somewhat cordial i will
get involved if i have to again i am an
authoritarian at heart when it comes to
moderation uh and i will i will be your
idiom mean if necessary so i'll allow
you all to engage in open discussion who
wants to start us off
i'd like to actually um adam something
as uh as a new star i'll let him go
mortalities thank you so so this notion
about that like zielinski was an actor
therefore is incompetent and every
country in eastern europe is run by
incompetent people i mean this is i'm
sorry this is some like boomer tier
american uh centric [ __ ]
uh
uh i i believe ronald reagan was also an
actor when he came to power so like i
don't know if we're like also donald you
had donald trump as a president so like
you know shush on that
um actually xenosky has been doing a
pretty good job of course
political inexperience uh was a big deal
actually it was a big branding point
also in the campaign the rest of eastern
europe are run by people who are either
run by generally very experienced people
however uh many of them are of the far
right variety including victor orban my
dear prime minister so
uh to characterize the the the ukrainian
situation from the uh from that
perspective i mean i think it's pretty
like just like misinformed but but then
again i'm i'm very much used to people
uh talking about the ukraine situation
from purely an american perspective like
i've heard people saying oh yeah we
shouldn't intervene at all you know it's
a it's america first and it's like well
good but like you're kind of forgetting
about like like
what do we do with europe then you know
uh
anyway i'll let other people go i need
to
uh hear some other points from others as
well well
if i might you know i have i have no so
the question was phrases the west bay in
america obviously is one of the biggest
contributors to to nato in fact um
donald trump actually did something very
good by making nato pay up a little bit
tiny tiny tiny bit more into
contributing to the alliance because i
made a lot of the european countries
like to spend on social safety nets as
opposed to actually defending their own
country so america has tended to pick up
the slack for them um but i have no
problem if the european powers want to
move on this issue and really i have no
personal objection if america wants to
move on this issue either but i don't
want america to move on the issue in
ways that are immoral um sanctions are
and more whether they're sanctions
against china whether it's against
russia they're fundamentally immoral
because what they are doing is they are
trying to disrupt
an individual's ability to economically
trade with someone else in a different
country um
i i think putin's subterfuge in crimea
is also immoral as well but here's the
problem i'm not i'm not arguing that
putin is some sort of uh hero or
whatever obviously he's a bad actor who
wants to expand his power and who wants
to uh you know source in his idea
restore the glory of the russian uh
republic or whatever federation or
whatever my question is this who whose
obligation is it to stop him is it
america's if so how do you justify that
obligation upon what grounds justify
that obligation that's my questions
okay one at a time we're gonna have
kevin respond and then um i'll write
pixel down
yeah no i think it's really interesting
because normally when people talk about
the morality of the situation they they
usually concede that the west has the
moral high ground here because it's a
sovereign country being aggressed upon
by an imperial power but when they when
people usually give their hesitancy to
support ukraine it's usually justified
as well we don't want to accidentally
start a nuclear war or something but
you're actually it's interesting you're
making a moral argument that the west
isn't bound to defend ukraine you're not
even going with the potential nuclear
war argument which i find very
interesting so you you're saying here
christian
you're saying that well crimea was wrong
and i'm guessing you probably think that
what china's doing in xinjiang right now
to the uyghurs is also wrong you just
think it's wrong to do anything about it
i would say that that's a gross no also
qualification no it's a gross
falsification i would say this by what
means or by what right does the west
have any sort of uh moral high ground
here or what the by what means does the
west have
an incumbency to act here i would say
very very simple the defense of the
liberal order a rules-based uh world
that we want to see and we want to
prevent a slippery slope a domino effect
of putin taking ukraine and then coming
in and taking poland or trying to take
lithuania etc because you might say it's
all about america eventually by your
logic russia will literally be on
america's borders because what logic
would you have to defend any other ally
if you will not defend ukraine in other
words if if western democracy doesn't
matter in ukraine why does it matter
anywhere this is a ridiculous like
slippery slope argument right like the
promotion of western democracy abroad as
a foreign policy goal that we've used
war to achieve
democracy i'm just saying defending an
existing democracy i want to hear
christian's response though
first of all i didn't equivocate at all
to equivocate is to make two distinct
things seem similar not to that at all
is number one number two you're saying
the west i'm saying the united states
now i made a distinction earlier because
the west also includes european powers
and it was clear the european powers
have the ability to act in this fund if
they want to my question is particularly
focused on america and america america's
moral obligation now you seem to be
sourcing america's moral obligation in
this sort of grand abstraction of
liberal western democracy or whatever
that means that we have this sort of um
this sort of obligation to defend it
again where does that obligation come
from how does america have an obligation
to defend abstractions especially
abstractions that are external from its
own borders that's my question i'm not
saying that
i'm not no i'm not saying i'm not saying
well you should
should take my arguments for what they
are
you should believe in liberty right or
does liberty only matter within your own
order okay so no no no no no you're
you're kind of taking my arguments to a
place where they need not be taken
because it's not logical it'll take them
there i'm not saying liberty is specific
to certain nations or certain nations or
its values certain nations what i'm
saying is um that different nations
interact with liberty in a very
different way and obviously there's a
correct way to do that but i think a
nation has first and foremost an
obligation to its own people
so the idea that america has an
obligation to defend liberty everywhere
is this idea which has had america spend
over two trillion dollars on two
conflicts that were utilized by
bureaucrats who used abstractions george
w bush used abstractions we're going to
fight terror we're going to they used
abstractions as a means to move the
goalposts
excuse me wait wait okay we need to let
christian finish because christian was
uh finishing this point then we're gonna
we have pixel we have um adam as well
the way george bush phrased america's
effort to fight terror was most
certainly an abstraction and it was
built on abstract grounds because
instead of actually getting a
declaration of war what did he do he
went to congress to give him an
authorization of the use of military
force that same authorization was used
to ensure america and several other
conflicts across the middle east and
we're still we've pulled out a lot
thanks to trump and a lot of other and
obama a little bit a little bit although
he decided to go ahead and go bombing
can we eliminate it
because there's like nine people here
it's gonna be like if every answer is
like okay here's my point here's my
point here's my point america does not
have a moral obligation to defend quote
unquote liberty around the world america
has a moral obligation first and
foremost to its own citizens this does
not mean that liberty itself is not
important but it does mean that there
are different actors who have different
degrees of responsibility for different
people's liberties around the world
don't let the world fall and then fight
no wait let's keep streaming
let's point it do you think it was
immoral for the us to intervene during
the cuban missile crisis
um i think we caused the people missing
let them answer that okay don't use a
lot of that we do i want to know
immoral for at the stage when missiles
are being shipped to cuba do you think
it's immoral for the united states to
intervene at that point or should they
well no not no not in that particular
circumstance but we actually we actually
had a very big role in causing that
question
all i'm trying to establish is that
hold on destiny it's important to know
what caused it it's not important
wait
what i'm trying to establish is that
american interest obviously can exist
outside of america's borders there are
things that can happen around the world
that will have an impact on our very own
citizens in the united states the cuban
missile crisis is an obvious one whether
you think down the road we caused it or
didn't cause it that is an obvious case
of things can happen outside u.s borders
that are interested uh that have like a
u.s interest attached to them the
defense of nato of our trade routes of
our multilateral trade agreements as the
world hegemony where the united states
guarantees the freedom of certain
countries is ultimately important to us
interests in a direct way and in many
indirect ways i think that's a fair
point to say so i think if we want to
attack our uh interest in ukraine we can
do that you can attack that but i don't
think you can just simply dismiss it by
saying oh well it's not in our borders
so it's not a u.s interest i think
that's a very naive way of looking at
how the world connects today
and i i don't think that's the case i
think that the preservation of the
global economy is one of the most
important things that we can do not just
for the
preservation of america and nato but for
the preservation of world peace because
with more economic trade across the
world the more peace there has been
because we're more connected so i'm not
saying that but it's very important to
know who caused the conflict because if
you cause the conflict you therefore
have an obligation to go ahead and take
care of the conflict and that's the
source of my argument america the moral
obligation to deal with the mess america
called the cuban missile crisis was on
america you know and so the moral
obligation in terms of ukraine though
that's my question that i haven't really
still got an answer for that let's say
that russia rolls into ukraine takes it
over then let's say russia begins to
expand into other countries and takes
them over let's say these are countries
that are effectively removed from a u.s
fear of influence let's say that there
are eventually more restrictive trade
barriers put on them we'll say by russia
that inhibit them from trading from
europe or american allies isn't this
reduction in worldwide economic freedom
and negative in your view
sure sure well but if we presume russia
is going to do that i mean i don't i
don't i have no clue if putin wants to
take over the entirety of europe i don't
know that i know you certainly don't
expect
everybody's this is what everybody's
saying right
so russia already has like world tanks
into georgia russia already owns the
peninsula um we can't just say slippery
slope every time we try to establish
some like chain of events i think it's
fair to say that given the opportunity
to and if and even with like the world
crying against him it seems like putin
doesn't mind rolling russian authority
out into different places if he was able
to not even take over eastern ukraine
but the entire rest of ukraine why is it
a slippery slope to assume that he might
try to extend that even further
by the way putin has already said that
with ukraine the ultimatum essentially
russia gave an ultimatum to nato and
like western nations in general saying
that if if you don't guarantee us that
ukraine will never be part of nato and
nato will stop expanding et cetera if
you don't guarantee that in writing
then uh then of course we're going to
invade and we also want the essentially
the full restoration of of the cold war
era spheres of influence that means
about 12 countries back into the neutral
zone
but as the saying in eastern europe goes
uh if you choose nato nato comes if you
choose russia russia comes if you choose
nobody russia comes so this is the
situation we find ourselves in well
we're in a situation
wait wait wait has broken hey kevin okay
we got other people that need to talk uh
some people have talked to decent amount
we got pixel uh taft and stein adam did
you say what you wanted to say i just
wanted to make sure i believe you i
believe yes okay so we're going to go in
that order from the people when they
raise their hand pixel taft and stein in
that order
well my previous point is relatively
moot now but i will say that as a
high-value female
on this panel i actually think i have
just come up with a solution for this
problem have we tried um minting ukraine
as an nft because i hear that's the way
you can own like the original deed to
something these days so if we just put
it on the blockchain
um then it'll be very clear to everyone
where uh ukraine stands do you know what
i mean like i've solved it i just fixed
everything you're very welcome
congratulations uh next is gonna be taft
i mean i want to address what steven
said because he brought up the cuban
missile crisis and the cuban missile
crisis is not analogous to the situation
in ukraine uh when russia moves missiles
to cuba that's a direct threat to
america russian troops in ukraine's
border is not something that's worth
going to war over so then we start
talking about well what if russia starts
moving west state by state until it
really does pose a real threat to
american global hegemony
hegemony right let's say that like
russia's just conquering land after land
well yeah then it would pose a real
threat but you know it would make
fighting that war easier if we're not
you know turning it into a big war right
now but instead waiting for russia to
engage in protracted urban warfare
probably for years in
a hostile environment so i mean i think
that's an absurd scenario which i don't
think would ever come true but if that's
the kind of like hypothetical we're
dealing with then yeah the united states
should still avoid starting war
escalating war
until until there's a real reason to
until there's a real threat to americans
because like christian said who america
has an obligation to it's not ukrainian
it's americans
so your solution is let russia go in
loot pillage the towns and cities of
ukraine and potentially kill tens of
thousands of ukrainians but they'll do
an insurgency and hope it works out so
your your solution is to just ruin a
country one and a half times the size of
canada that's embarrassing that's that's
nobody's suggesting a war we're saying
if you put the troops in there putin
obviously isn't going to go in and fight
american troops he's deterred by america
so i i'm okay we'll back up a little bit
because i agree then after stein
um i think sending weapons to ukraine is
totally legitimate and like posturing is
legitimate um these are like tactics
that we can take i don't think that
putin or russia wants an actual war with
the united states and neither does the
united states actually want a war with
russia so what this is really about is
russia's demanding that we come to the
negotiating table and they're strong
arming us into doing this and the reason
is is because they're worried about the
expansion of american power so go to the
negotiating table and work with them and
created a deal that's actually going to
create lasting solutions like what we
almost had in iran that would be
fantastic
why would that work
stein was saying i i just i just want to
make my point because it's something
that destiny said about the cuban
missile crisis and we can look up uh
operation northwoods in operation north
which was a plan to hijack uh planes
during the cuban missile crisis and make
it look like it was uh cuban nationals
and then flight into buildings in miami
to start a war so we'd have a reason to
start a war with the cubans you can look
this up and then what happened on
september 11 2001 19 hijackers with
razor blades supposedly box cutters
supposedly defeated the greatest army
in the world the most defense army in
the world and then knocked down three
towers with two planes that story is
laughable but we'll forget about that so
what happened with that after that i'm
just saying you know i believe it's an
inside job but we're not here to debate
that but what i'm saying is after that
you know what i'm saying i don't care
what you say i'm the conspiracy castle
it was an inside job orchestrated by
people within our our government and
israel and saudi arabia but that doesn't
matter this is what i'm saying
so let's
we can get into it but this is what i'm
saying let me just make my point so what
happened that that started a basically a
20-year war in the middle east why who
did that benefit probably israel the
most because the seven biggest countries
ever threatened it but it doesn't matter
what i'm saying bring it back
let me just talk about what i'm trying
to say so so it goes to ukrainian border
so what happened in afghanistan we don't
have to worry about our tin foil hat you
guys don't have to believe me on all
that do you guys think america won the
war on terror in the middle east do you
think the evacuation of afghanistan was
good do you think that if you were if
you were a country in need of being
attacked by russia would you want the
united states the people that botched
the vietnam war the people that
literally that there are soldiers that
had a tar pit where the the u.s multiple
us army bases they had their their where
they burn their trash and their poop and
for a lot of soldiers are sick because
that pit was too close to the bases this
is how dumb the united states military
is they'll even tell you that guys with
a box cutters took down the twin towers
they couldn't get the norad jets so i'm
telling you this military the
military-industrial complex of the
united states is a bunch of autistic
morons so if i was a ukraine and my only
choice to have exactly hang on a second
yeah look i mean first i mean by the way
911 was had nothing to do with the u.s
military that was a civilian plane and
terrorist inside it so let's let's
that's what you believe i i think
there's a lot of evidence yeah yeah yeah
yeah with the echoes yeah okay whatever
so anyway um so with regards to whether
ukraine should want uh well whether
afghanistan iraq et cetera and like
failure failures of the russian of the
us army
should factor into ukraine no ukraine is
not like iraq it's not like afghanistan
or vietnam no it doesn't matter
america's bad armies they'll become a
good army and they're ukraine all of a
sudden
you know it is the most
american is the most overwhelmingly
powerful nation on the planet i have no
idea where you get this idea from that
people then
okay wait we gotta be careful wait uh
dude you gotta you gotta wait you gotta
you gotta
you gotta stop
stop boomer
okay okay you gotta calm down okay wait
wait wait you got it you gotta calm down
energy okay alex sorry what is your
energy as beta or soy energy what i mean
i'm 99 i'm just saying you're trying to
say the military is good
you got to let them respond though you
ask them a question you know you got to
let respond adam
sure so uh the ukraine situation is
nothing like afghanistan or iraq
thankfully this was a nation that
actually petitioned western support from
2014 after the overthrow the president
who was pro-russian and then ended up
you know
ordering police to open fire at grounds
100 people died
and then came the insurgency in ukraine
most of ukraine actually
the
vast majority of ukraine supports nato
membership is pro-american and supports
ego membership this is a country which
is very closely aligned already all on
the population level and a military
level with the us so for you to suggest
that uh so you know there won't be
ukrainian intelligence military is so
good why do they need our help then if
they're on the same level
adam if they're on the streets
no no on the same level how
saying that the same ingenuity of
military
they need us because
they need our help
we have the same size military you just
insinuated
as far as i could tell that we're on the
same level diplomatically like they're
like like when it comes to like alliance
structure at least that's what it felt
like okay okay i thought he meant
same-sex military like
like i thought he meant like where this
is why would they need our help
well i thought you're insinuating we're
the same military as them i mean you
could say that they're our allies but
right how is russia how is russia not
our allies we hear the international
space station
america dude you know what i'm saying we
should you're
i'm
you're
we have treaties with russia and who's
the only person who's ever dropped a
nuke the united states they're the only
person that's ever dropped this is the
fascist empire that attacked america way
to victim blame america dude that like
yeah
i know putin's not a big enough idiot to
send nuclear weapons in blow up america
because i know putin has half a brain
that's why i know that and you probably
know that too that they're not going to
start a nuclear holocaust
you know that over ukraine you know that
so you're trying to act all scared oh
i'm so scared of russia why don't you
wake up why don't you live your life
stop living in here these rockets that
putin's pointing at you okay okay okay
i mean i mean okay okay so we're gonna
move on we gotta move on to destiny
because destiny's been waiting to see a
decent bit to talk raised his hand
earlier destiny i'm not sure what um am
i responding to the 911 hijacker thing
or um it was it was a while ago i forget
i think it was in response to what taft
where um
yeah i feel like this idea of waiting
until it's too late is is kind of like
eerily similar to the hitler thing
although i don't like to draw
comparisons to world war two because
obviously the whole landscape is quite a
bit different than it was back then but
i don't think that we could wait for
russia to take over ukraine and then
maybe start encroaching into poland and
then at that point like oh [ __ ] maybe
now we need to do something because then
we're going to be back at ground zero
for this conversation and instead we're
going to be having a panel in you know
four years saying like well should the
united states support poland on the
ground and it's like well if we put
troops there like that's pretty
aggressive and i don't know like just
because they took over poland like they
really going to go even further you know
like it's only like georgia or crimea
ukraine like is it right you know summer
poland like i feel like you kind of have
to draw a line in the sand pretty early
so that the rest of the world knows
where you stand especially your allies
like is the united states going to be a
reliable partner here to protect you
here because if not it seems like uh
similar to a domino effect the united
states is going to not stand by its you
know kind of worldwide obligation um to
prevent the encroaching or encroachment
of russia into other countries then why
not just roll over immediately and join
russia sooner rather than wait for the
inevitable
conflict uh can i ask stephen a question
sure taft you were the first to raise
your hand yeah
yeah it's just gonna be a short one
in your estimation what do you think was
the reason or objective
in the united states decision to enter
the european theater in world war ii
um what was the objective what was our
goal there
well hitler declared war on america
yeah well i mean my i thought there was
a dry declaration war from japan and
then germany so i thought we kind of had
to get involved at that point or were we
i don't know like i'm sure for
objectives i'm sure there were multiple
objectives but um i don't know why don't
you tell me
yeah i mean there are probably two
objectives right okay either one to stop
the holocaust or
that's what that's absolutely nobody
knew about the holocaust the holocaust
had nothing just saying that there's
like multiple objectives that people you
know put forth right
yeah holocaust was not one of them but
what's the second one you're gonna say
okay
yeah obviously you know the average
american troop and the people entering
the european theater at the time were
not
i would say their goal was not to stop
the holocaust
but some people make this argument
the other one is to defeat germany right
and to contain the german expansion
and
what we got by entering world war ii in
the european theater was we
worked with russia to contain germany
but another strategy in hindsight would
have been to let russia and germany go
to war with each other tire each other
out and then come in at the end and
defeat germany deliver the final blow
liberate europe and then have a weaker
russian soviet empire to deal with in
the cold war post war
yeah no well irrelevant even for that
who's to say that germany wouldn't have
just continued to take over the
entirety of europe
they wouldn't have though right because
because they didn't have the
overwhelming
force necessary to do that they made it
hold on
i'm
hold on wait wait wait okay i'm really
bad at history i'm gonna be the first to
admit that okay okay but
germany blitzcreate the entire [ __ ]
continent they absolutely had the
overwhelming force to to take over to
finish with the united
kingdom how they but it was russia that
overwhelmingly put a stopped them in yo
hold on no no no no wait wait hold on
wait wait wait wait wait okay
russia did not put a stop to germany in
europe russia put a stop to germany in
russia because germany pushed really
really really far east but my
understanding is they had no trouble
sweeping completely west across the
entire continent of europe until u.s
troops were on the ground
but russia's intention was to go
straight to berlin which they did do
and in the alternate history where
america waits right to enter and lets
the european powers fight for a longer
time the european powers couldn't fight
though they were they completely were
steamrolled the only reason russia was
probably able to push as far as ignoring
lend lease and the uh economic
assistance from the united states was
probably because there was so much
pressure on the western front as well
i mean i think we can talk about like
the american production machine which
was universal not production it was uh
are you discounting us troops on the
west because yeah stalin was desperate
for those stella and big stalin said he
couldn't do it on his own that's what he
told churchill and fdr that's stalin he
even said he couldn't do it
even without len lease like the us like
boots on the ground were essential like
the the the push back into europe didn't
begin without u.s blood
happening there was no amount of
production i think that would have saved
the would have saved the rest of europe
from german encroachment
i think the analogy that i'm drawing
here is just that sometimes if you allow
people to war with each other for longer
if you put in a bit of wait time you
might allow them to deplete resources
yeah but the scary thing about
scary thing about this is
this is like oh this is my last point
and then a lot of people started we're
engaging in like
we're attempting to do so much guesswork
here that there are
to say that this is the most likely
event is impossible there's a million
ways that this could have played out it
might have been that at some point
russia and germany reach an uneasy peace
or maybe even align with each other like
they did when they uh caught up poland
and were working on what was essentially
an alliance it wasn't just an
unaggressive it was essentially an
alliance they were agreeing to split
territories and non-address against each
other um it might have been that they
would have stepped back to that it might
have been that hitler would have
discovered nuclear weapons quicker than
the united states and a germany that
owns 90 of europe and has nukes is a
germany that's going to continue to own
90 of europe um it might have been that
without the us being involved in the war
maybe japan and germany together are
able to focus on russia once the entire
european continent leaving the uk aside
like there's a million other ways that
that could have played out to say that
like oh well let's just wait and starve
them out is one potential future but i
feel like there's a hundred million
other potential futures with with the
vast majority of them looking in there's
999 099 horrible scenarios only one of
them ends up you know good possibly i
think you're making a fantastic point
you're right in the like the actual
reality of the war when we entered the
war that was like probably the best
decision of the time and it's only like
looking back in hindsight and knowing
and being able to review the strategic
plans of these powers that you can make
these sort of conjectures of like maybe
in this alternate history would have
been effective right
i think we've like sort of gone down a
weird path because you're making like
good points in that like it would not
have necessarily been a good decision to
wait it out at the time because we
didn't have like the info to know that
that would be effective however my point
is that you know just jumping into a war
is not necessarily the kind of thing
that you want to do and with ukraine
even if there is like war even if
russia is invading ukraine
um we don't want to be the ones who are
like the first people that russia's
encountering as far as troops that are
battling them
not um to send troops if the us puts
troops like if the us puts a significant
number of troops like say 10 000 to
ukraine putin's not dumb putin doesn't
want to die in a nuclear war he's not
going to invade the question is if we
let a war happen this is a great irony
by trying to prevent a war and doing the
chamberlain thing in appeasement that's
what's actually going to get us a war
that's actually what's going to get us
russian troops and tanks steamrolling
into kiev and other cities and looting
and pillaging and eventually you know
they will come for the west i i don't
like this idea that we can choose
between nipping them in the bud when
it's easy or waiting until we're back at
berlin and now those are the battle
lines why like unless you're on their
side why wouldn't you want our forces on
their border instead of their forces
getting closer to our borders basically
kevin did you just say you're not
worried about putin
shooting nuclears at the united states
is that what you just said hold on hold
on i said if the u.s puts troops can you
just say that didn't you justify this
question
you did say it hammer him on it take him
out dude
he didn't say that so you're just you
just
okay
kevin dylan i can't hear them when you
keep interrupting
okay thank you yeah so look i i want to
be clear about something i never claimed
that putin's planning to just nuke all
american cities tomorrow what alex
claimed earlier was why aren't we
working with russia this and that my
point was you can't really work with a
country that shares none of your values
competing economic interests a different
geopolitical project with eurasianism
etc completely different interests even
if russia was a democracy with alexei
navalny they'd still oppose nato over
just geopolitics anyway my point was
they're aiming 8 000 nukes in america i
didn't say that putin's planning to
necessarily use them but my point was
friends don't aim nukes at each other
and this idea of russia's our friend is
it harks back to the madison square
garden protest of oh well hitler's our
friend why not peace it ultimately boils
down to it always goes back
are we in nato with russia kevin
nato is in opposition to russia okay so
we're in an alliance with russia okay so
we are in line are you
stupid why are you leaving yeah
that's why i asked i didn't know if
russia was a part of nato that's why i
asked i thought
everything about it
okay about nato
we got it we gotta shut this down for a
second okay because we have to move on
and i'm going to so a few people raised
their hand uh including i just saw you
uh christian so the people who raised
their hand are
parker adam and
uh christian so i'll start with parker
oh my god i put my hand up so [ __ ]
hard i didn't see it it's fine it's fine
am i hidden behind your [ __ ]
microphone again dylan no it's just you
raised your hand so high was out it was
out of screen so i couldn't see it
well i tried multiple different ways
you'll be on the list two pixel okay uh
parker
uh so i kind of want to take the
conversation a bit back to where we were
in the beginning um i i want to sort of
combat this notion that like russia
could actually like like feasibly like
have enough political or economic power
to steamroll through multiple different
nations um without a response from nato
at all um i don't think that they could
get to the borders of like poland or a
different country like that and then
we'd still have people saying like oh i
don't want to uh respond i don't think
that we'd have any type of response like
that i definitely think that people are
like would notice that if they're trying
to go like to uh invade ukraine they
would probably try to uh do that to
other countries as well um but i don't
think they have the political economic
stability to uh like start that type of
war or start that type of uh like um
interaction
parker you'd be surprised by the
anti-imperialists out there that can't
wait to cheer for russian imperialism
there are a lot of people that would say
what right do we have to protect poland
they'd be fine with waving nato
obligations right well that's an
extremely small amount of people the
overwhelming majority of people would if
if they like invaded ukraine would say
that oh yeah we have to stop like a
russian aggression to at least some
extent wait wait
wait historically this is but we didn't
do this with crimea or with georgia no
didn't we all just sit by like wow
that's really bad
yeah well
to that specific degree i i mean i i do
you think that's like a valid point 100
but like when we're talking about like
ukraine versus like crimea i think
there's a big distinction between at
least those times because especially
like in 2014 uh
i mean i wasn't around at that time i
don't know what the type of a
conversation was at that time i'm a
little too young
yeah no i mean well like i wasn't around
like i didn't like actually pay
attention to politics at all but like
yeah i mean i'm sure you remember i'm
sure you heard at least one time in
school you probably heard like russia is
in georgia and then i'm sure kids in
class like georgia the state and like no
georgia the country's like oh okay and
then like we never heard about it again
because what about me and not georgia at
all
we just don't care much about foreign
policy um like ukraine is another thing
like
anything that russia gets its hands on
it's not going to give back so
well yeah i mean if they if they started
some like front like into ukraine people
would have a response we've already had
they already yeah but they already are
like they're already in
the nets don't they just have troops at
the border they haven't actually like no
they've taken about 80 000 square
kilometers in the east in la concentra
and uh crimea dude and the thing is
their nuclear power nobody suggested
going in by force and taking them back
the problem is once they get territory
as destiny said that's god like their
nuclear power we're never getting that
back so why not nip it in the bud and
stop them from going further as opposed
to letting them take more and then now
we have this debate again right that's
that's how did you stop them
okay
so okay so who was who was that directed
towards kevin and then they need to get
back to the list because there's other
people waiting yeah well i guess that
question in general it wasn't so much
directed towards parker parker was just
kind of asking some clarifying questions
my point was just more general why don't
we this is the question i guess i'll
direct this to tough touch to conspiracy
castle and the christian in particular
why why would you guys prefer to forfeit
ukraine and then have to deal with
russian aggression when the battle lines
are closer to us why not nip it in the
bud just put in some troops there and
send a message to putin to say look uh
we're not going to tolerate wars against
democracies in europe because we know if
we let this go it'll be another one and
another one because they've demonstrated
this with georgia in 2008 and craig and
crimean the rest of the train in 2014.
i'm going to have christian respond
because christian raised his hand hasn't
been able to talk in a while so i'm
gonna have christian respond to that
question so it was directed towards so
yeah
i'll be very quick before i respond to
that question we have to deal with this
argument that if you're somehow
skeptical of using military uh force not
against russia but in proximity to
russia's geopolitical aggression you are
somehow on russia's side i can give you
two reasons that are not at all
pro-russia but are instead pro-other
things pro-common sense rather that
would lead us skeptical to such incur
incursions number one the the question
of moral obligation towards other
countries which i mentioned earlier
which wasn't really answered uh number
two um the erosion of american
diplomatic capital through in continued
aggression and number three the
continuation of american imperialism
which has caused destruction and chaos
across the world those are three reasons
why someone could be reasonably
skeptical of going into this with a more
aggressive stance that had nothing to do
with being pro-russia and the assertion
that if you are against this some kind
of force towards russia in this
circumstance europe russia is absolutely
an ad hominem of the lowest sort so
let's not use that argument anymore um
now as for the battle lines and
everything look i'm not saying let
russia seize ukraine i'm asking what and
i'm saying the european powers some of
whom have again different degrees of
moral obligation and different degrees
of interest in ensuring that ukrainian
remains in sovereign hands um they have
the ability to act i'm particularly
concerned about the united states
obligation or lack of obligation lack
the rebel obligation um towards ukraine
and really i have no problem with the
united states using diplomatic capital
to um you know and even what taft said i
mean the listening very closely i have
no problem even supplying them with
weapons now the problem is america has
supplied people with weapons in the past
and they've gotten into the wrong hands
so i i typically can't be very skeptical
of that but i have no problem even
supplying them with weapons and i do not
do not think biden should have pulled
out our diplomatic um personnel and now
there is a wind scheme unless he was
married mad at him for that so there are
steps we can take to ensure that ukraine
remains somewhat in america's fear of
geopolitical influence but those steps
should not at all elevates the level of
military aggression even if it's just
placing troops on ukraine's border this
the united has no obligation to do so so
christian who do you think is the
imperial power in the ukraine russia
dynamic do you think it's russia or do
you think it's america that's an obvious
question obviously russia's the imperial
power but one's imperialism does not
negate others imperialism america has
been an imperialist nation for many many
many many many decades and that needs to
be dealt with
a sovereign country resists russian
imperialism how is that imperialist
that's a straw man i i just i just gave
you a few examples how you can actually
help them without putting troops on the
ground putting boots on the ground is
another example of american imperialism
having diplomatic personnel is not yes
yes absolutely so defending yes
their sovereign government asks for help
it's not like we're just invading them
their sovereign country their sovereign
government
for military support and you say we
can't help you that would be imperialism
is that no no i didn't say you are
pretending like i'm saying that you
cannot help them at all i'm saying there
are more ways to help ukraine there are
more ways to help ukraine there are more
ways to help ukraine you're
characterizing sending troops there to
deter an invasion you're characterizing
that
in the prop
in the in the context of the american
global project absolutely having
thousands of troops situated across the
world across europe and countries that
we are absolutely not even at war with
yes i absolutely think that's a
parallelism of a certain kind of sort
it is imperialism
imperialism is going in and taking over
other people's [ __ ] other people's
countries without their permission
that's one function of its one function
okay i can't hear myself think and if i
can't hear myself think then nobody can
hear [ __ ] so i'm going to have kevin
respond then i'm going to have christian
respond and then we're gonna move on to
pixel adam then taft does anybody want
their like name written down but of
course you can like interview at some
point the tap i just said your name
yes
but he called out like four people i
can't have every person respond okay
okay yeah you guys can be on the left
can you add me to the list please okay
sure but thank you last resort but do i
get to respond now or later
wouldn't make her respond later later
but it would actually have to be later
it would happen to stephen
yeah he is mean but i'm also mean so um
you're terrible christian um you respond
then uh i mean no kevin responded then
christian you can say in front of word
we gotta move on to pixel than adam okay
okay so basically
calling uh the american president say
america sends sa says
vladimir zielinski asked for say 8 000
troops and biden agrees to that uh and
of course zielinski's democratically
elected leader of ukraine you can cope
about being a reality tv guy or whatever
trump is a reality tv guide alex i'm not
saying that to christian but here's the
thing here's the thing so you go and say
you put 8 000 troops in there and
they're there say is a deployment of you
know uh similar to what we did in canada
with operation uh uh unifor there a
unifier there and we they're just there
as uh basically a deterrent against the
russian invasion my my sort of point was
that that's not a an imperialist act
that's actually a consensual
uh a defense agreement between two
sovereign countries and so the only
reason why you could think of that as
imperialist is if you've unfortunately
fallen for russian disinformation and
propaganda and you can say you're not
pro-russia i don't think you like putin
i'm just saying that the consequence of
your inaction is necessarily pro-putin
in how that would manifest in reality
because you would render ukraine
vulnerable to an invasion this is why we
call it peace through strength not peace
through relativism or peace through
weakness thank you
well i'd like to make a point was it
imperialistic during the the afghan uh
when we were leaving afghanistan and we
uh we dropped a missile and we killed
four children four innocent children i
mean was that interesting damage that
wasn't done on purpose so that's not
imperialistic so those people when
they're died they're just taking they're
just collaterals after isis it's bad to
go after aces okay
but killing four children or isis k i
didn't know i didn't know children could
be in isis i want to hear from christian
because i'm just saying collateral
damages
yes i do you're saying that we're not
imperialistic though yeah we're the ones
that go into it we've done in the middle
east we're very imperialistic okay alex
the point i want to make sure christian
goes we're the ones that kill kids you
love it there's just collateral damage
and four-year-olds get killed look at
you're smiling it's so cute okay smiling
because you're a goober dude okay
christian
so when i say imperialism so what so
what superpower broadcasting is saying
yes conquering a country and staying
there obviously is going to be a
functional imperialism but imperialism
is a multi-function multi-purpose
concept so conquering a country through
military force certainly is
imperialistic but going into a country i
don't care if it was consensual or
otherwise and projecting a hegemony
projecting power through military force
is an extension of the american global
project which has been imperialistic and
as laws of logic work a prim a premise a
premise is the basis for a conclusion
and the premise of america's
intervention in ukraine is going to be
its general imperialistic um project
even if that particular action is not as
severe or not as you know as blatant as
other acts of american imperialism have
been in the past so again it's this is
from the same family even if it has a
different face so to speak and also
again this argument that i am somehow um
in putin's uh pocket because i may have
a position that he may favor is nonsense
you should not
you you should not analyze the position
on the basis
you you should not you should not
analyze a position's moral correctness
or in moral wrongness on the basis of
who supports it rather analyze the
position on the merits itself if a
dictator were to support the proposition
that two plus two was four that does not
make that proposition any more wrong
than if mother teresa were to support it
it's about the proposition's inherent
correctness that's we look at and if
even if putin does think that you know
obviously doesn't think america should
get involved because i would obviously
be a arrest in his plans that doesn't
necessarily mean that that position is
tannic because he supports it so that's
all i have to say okay so
no seven kevin sorry we gotta move on to
so many people have to talk we gotta
throw it over to pixel then
um i'd just like to add some further
context as to what is going on like in a
geopolitical context here because if
we're talking about imperialism we are
living in a time right now where
basically everything that is happening
is going to be political posturing
nobody is
like seriously going to launch a nuke
knowing that any sort of war at this
point uh is going to result in basically
runaway climate change which is bad for
everyone even if we're already on that
path
um so understanding why russia's
posturing towards ukraine is maybe
seeming so aggressive now has to include
the fact that china is also um
an imperialist power moving towards uh
russia from the south through the stands
and so russia
at this point are feeling like uh they
have to make some sort of shoal of force
uh to make sure that they retain their
perceived power um or at least
their perceived position in the global
kind of geopolitical mess because it's
all just posturing at this point
some of it is aggressive and some of it
at the moment feels extremely
uncomfortable but it is being built up
by american media as well because that
serves its own narrative purpose in
america it serves a narrative purpose
here in australia as well because
obviously you know we have um an
interesting uh where america's [ __ ]
little brother but we are also in uh
like the realm of uh china's
geopolitical influence and so like you
can't just look at this between america
and russia because it is so much more
complex than that and the reasons that
russia
are moving into ukraine um is because of
resources but also just for the
political posturing anyway i just wanted
to provide the context to make it a bit
bigger okay next we're gonna throw it
over to adam
sure so a couple of points have been
made with which i'd like to which i'd
like to clarify so um
uh first off the christian of course no
one said that you're in the pocket of
putin uh however you have to realize
that the positions you advocate for they
align almost perfectly with with russian
geopolitical goals so i mean that's you
know people some people
based on what i've heard i know that you
aren't uh i you just like me as a
genuine guy uh however some people might
interpret this as you being pro putin
because you're aligned so well so i
think that's that's the issue there uh
as to whether the us has a moral
obligation to help ukraine well after we
have uh essentially
by we i mean the western world and also
the us so let's talk about the u.s so
since the u.s has already promised
ukraine that they're going to help that
we have that they have made commitments
uh about ukraine's territorial in
uh
viability
uh that crimea belongs to ukraine that
donbass should be turned to ukraine uh
they made all these commitments promises
et cetera at this point to walk back and
say whoops
then i think that would be actually
breaking america's moral obligation so
whether likely or not these promises
have uh were made and have been made for
eight years uh to walk back back on them
now i think would be just horrendous
and regarding the other point that uh
def made uh i believe it was uh
just let's let's wait until they tire
each other out and then and then swoop
in
uh that is
i mean i guess you can do that from a
from a from a chessboard military
strategic perspective
but waiting until the two sides stir
each other out i mean that's just
millions more dead so why not intervene
uh generally during a conflict you know
as collateral so why not
intervene now of course as others said
early on
of course troops on the ground will not
happen though so let's let's i think we
can actually stop talking about this
american troops at least will not go to
ukraine uh what we're doing is
deterrence uh which is in line with the
us's moral obligations at this point
and contrary to russian interests which
which i fully support uh also like and
here's my problem actually
which is also a problem with my problem
with a substantial amount of the online
left
it's possible to oppose russian
imperialism and u.s imperialism at the
same time
uh however if if it's this is not the
case here but if your two choices if
choice a and choice b were you can
either get u.s imperialism in ukraine or
russian imperialism in ukraine then the
us imperialism would be better than the
russian imperialism because at least the
u.s is a democracy and russia is an
authoritarian country of course this is
not the case this is a false dichotomy
because this is not the case uh
in ukraine so there's there's no
imperialism it is it's an it's an uh u.s
and west oriented country asking for
help and it was promising for eight
[ __ ] years that we're gonna help and
now it's time to show your hands
basically
okay uh next we have taft then destiny
then we're probably gonna look at ending
statements for everybody
taft i'm honestly not sure if people
here disagree like that much because i
think in general we agree that we do
have some obligation to help ukraine
most people agree with that
and that that help should come at the
very least in the form of you know
sending arms to ukraine or helping to
negotiate a peace deal to bring people
to the table or you know to station
to station troops around if not
necessarily on the border because it you
know it doesn't seem like we're going to
be doing that necessarily
but i mean i think that there's like
there's this like analogy like if
someone were to pluck a blade of grass
from my lawn i don't risk nuclear war
with them over that
but if they come to my lawn the next day
with like
a machine to rip up the entire lawn well
then yeah that's like a serious problem
so
this like if russia's showing intention
to like invade europe
then yeah
there's definitely there's a serious
problem that is going to like they've
already invaded europe georgia 2008.
i don't think georgia is all of europe i
mean the u.s crimea the united states
wait what about crimea
right okay
the point is they're not like taking
state-by-state here
just parts of state just chauvinism
revenges and that kind of stuff right
okay let's let her finish her statement
i don't think that russia is going to
try to conquer europe um but if they do
try to conquer yep yeah in that scenario
we should go to war with them
okay and we're gonna wrap up with
destiny and you know what i'm just gonna
put alex stein at the end why not
oh yeah
um there's like three or four different
conversation threads earlier but they're
kind of like winding down now um so you
know what we should help ukraine that's
all i'm gonna say rather than reopen up
all that the other lines of
argumentation i guess
alex stein
you're muted you have muted yourself
duh sorry you can't hear me that whole
time okay everybody made fun of me
because i didn't know russia was not in
nato i guess i should have known that
but they we are in the united nations
together so i want to make that so i'm
not a total dummy but look at it there's
a movie called
listen beardo let me just say my deal
okay listen there's a movie called
charlie wilson's war what we did is we
funded the taliban we created the
taliban to fight and and we gave now
listen we gave them was formed in 1994
alex this is the previous version of the
taliban
okay they did they weren't called it so
you're saying that did we not arm rebels
in afghanistan
northern illinois listen listen they
weren't called the taliban so kevin are
you being so enough you're being so
annoying because you know that we've
funded afghanistan
excuse me let me we we gave afghanistan
rebels weapons to fight russia because
we're not going directly
against the communist empire listen
okay let me just make my point so you
agree that we gave weapons to
afghanistan
previous version of taliban so let me
let me show everybody you know
no almost all those guys went to the
northern alliance dude you're full of
[ __ ] you're full of [ __ ] you're not all
the [ __ ] i know exactly i'm the one
talking about it
you're the one listen listen i said i
asked if you're in it yo you're trying
listen you
i'm not uber
it's
what happens is we funded the mujahideen
so we basically fought a cold war with
russia
and russia wouldn't retaliate for that
we are never going to get in a war with
russia so you're saying oh we're so
scared you got all these weapons pointed
at us you've got all these rockets
they're going to shoot us yeah you even
admit that you're not afraid of that so
listen
about fear this is about value okay i'm
just saying i'm just saying what you
said so listen at the end of the day
the imperialistic no i'm not there's i'm
not pro russia i'm just based in reality
because i know that we've had we've had
more military interactions we've had
more military actions with russia that
are more intense in what's happening in
the ukraine and we still didn't have a
war so with this interaction right now i
don't believe it's going to lead to a
war so we don't need to put any troops
there so if you think oh by
putting a couple troops there that's
going to save us you're you're an
imbecile because the military industrial
complex the united states is is the main
country we have more military bases in
foreign countries than any other country
in the world so america isn't realistic
in america 800 russian babies listen all
you have to do is look at how the
americans uh how we treat our veterans
when they come back they're all hooked
on drugs they have a high suicide rate
yeah so if you're saying that yeah what
i'm saying so if you think that our
military is going to go to the ukraine
and help them then their whole
military's going to be all suicidal and
depressed
absolutely
and we'll just give them all uh ptsd and
they can all suicide themselves but
would you like that would you like that
better would that be better because
america is so good at america's so good
at everything oh because we're so good
at the imperialistic uh nature of
america okay
well i'm saying what do you think the
americas do you think the treatment of
veterans is correct in america do you
think we treat our veterans correct wait
a second yes this is so irrelevant yeah
but yeah
i understand both you love each other
very much and you just can't stop
complimenting each other uh but we do
need to go into ending statements and
i'm going to start with taft
or not i guess we're going to go with
kevin castle because half coats
okay thanks dylan yeah so basically the
clothes here i think we should just
reiterate a couple of points uh this
isn't a debate about what should we do
to stop a russian invasion or what
should we do to prevent a russian
invasion of ukraine russia has already
invaded europe in 2008 you can look up
if you haven't heard of it before i
would encourage everybody to look up the
russian invasion of georgia now
georgia's badass georgia was actually
involved in iraq at the time and they
also repelled uh
russia but we could have helped prevent
that whole cluster crap from happening
in the first place by actually having
troops there as a deterrent or better
yet if you don't want to put troops in
and i'll say this i'll say this if you
don't want to put troops in ukraine
there is another option if you don't
want to put troops in georgia there is
another option where you don't actually
have to put any us troops uh put them in
nato and now putin won't screw around
because then you've got article five and
now you get troops there if russia
invade so the best way to deal with this
would be to incorporate them in nato
that would require alterate nato's terms
so that you can put countries in nato
that have territorial disputes one
reason why putin took these territories
at south ossetia and abkhazia and
georgia was to prevent them from being
part of nato we need to alter the terms
of nato
to make it easier for countries to join
additionally uh we're talking about
stopping russia's further advance into
ukraine we're not talking about stopping
an invasion i am of the opinion and i
think that reality bears out in the
lessons of history bear out very well
that by preemptively and proactively
putting troops as a deterrent there we
stop a war from happening the great
irony in all of this is that all these
people tonight that fear-mongered about
a war the only war that's going to
happen with russia is if nobody helps
ukraine and then putin takes the w goes
in there and invades the country now
we've got tens of thousands of people
dead that could have been alive we have
a country of 44 million people their
hopes dreams and destinies have been
forfeited to fascist empire
because we didn't feel like putting a
few thousand troops in the ukraine it's
an embarrassment look i've got my
criticisms of justin trudeau but
right now he is totally one-upping joe
biden and joe biden should be 100
and entirely embarrassed by the fact
that canada you know despite us spending
not that much on the military we put
double the troops into ukraine and it's
not enough but we need to do more and we
are better off to nip in the bud and to
stop a war before it starts then to
accept a new status quo with russia with
russian troops in la vie and thank you
it's been interesting for everybody in
chat the links to everybody on the show
has been placed in chat if you're
wondering who everybody is and including
their marker on this
i'm now going to throw it over to taft
if they can learn how to stream
thanks dylan
uh to conclude i i agree that with the
fundamental premise that we should help
ukraine and i think that the priority
needs to be in
helping ukraine
negotiate and finding a peaceful
solution
and peace should be pursued aggressively
you know at all possible cost right
that's not true not at all possible you
should pursue peace aggressively peace
is really important war is really bad
and so we should try to deter war part
of the way you
deter war is by sending arms to ukraine
and to making sure ukraine doesn't seem
like a good target for invasion
and
moreover um but yeah
i mean that's that's my fundamental
point we should avoid war and we should
try to negotiate a peaceful solution
okay next we're gonna throw it over to
pixel
um
i agree that we should avoid war um but
we are now living in a time when
no nobody really wants to outright nuke
each other but we are going to have to
continue to navigate both soft and hard
imperialism i'm talking about like
australia offering aid to pacific
countries right that is political
influence and power and these things are
just going to keep happening so i'm not
sure if the idea of nipping something in
the bud is particularly valuable here
because these things are just going to
keep coming up as we move into the
future as like the
very intertwined
world that we are now um
that being said i do think that uh
depending on your ideology and mind
being relatively pro-democracy um
just as being a woman that is the
most comfortable i think
uh
ideology for me and how it has worked
out for women globally um
which is why uh sorry i'm getting
muddled over my words but basically
i think that
any show of support for democracy and
sovereignty
uh is valid in this situation navigating
like
global forces that continue to butt
heads
thanks
wonderful now i'm going to throw it over
to parker
okay so i specifically um
i don't think anyone or actually i'll
just say this i don't i don't think that
we should leave ukraine to russia i
definitely think that we should provide
some sort of help 100 i just think that
we should do that through diplomacy
sanctions and defense weapons and
whatnot obviously if there's a further
aggression from russia then we should
definitely uh
talk about how we should uh engage in at
least a little bit more of intervention
um but it's really just depend on what
we think is necessary in order to stop
russian aggression towards ukraine and i
don't think that uh the best way in
order to do that is just by sending
troops i think that can also bolster
russian propaganda and the fact that
like nato can be uh
aggressing towards russian borders um i
don't know how far to an extent that
would go but i definitely think that's
something that we should take into
account and we're talking about sending
troops there
wonderful i'm gonna throw it over to
destiny
man i'm gonna be honest i'm only here to
hear uh conspiracy castle's closing
statement but um yeah i think we should
support ukraine i think that russia is
very scared of having a even just a
functioning democracy on their border um
i think that's probably something that's
worth protecting both for ukrainian
interests and for broader us
geopolitical interests and for the
broader interests of all the countries
in the world that have decided to align
themselves with u.s interests i think
that we should show that we have the
capability of defending countries when
the time comes when we're called upon to
do it and this is as good a time as any
to stop russian aggression
wonderful now i'm going to throw it over
to christian
well you know i think we've we've seen a
lot of compelling arguments tonight
personally look the american global
project has to be a project of peace not
of war not of imperialism not of the
endless expansionism has to be one of
peace
and to any extent that's possible with
the situation i support if that means
not
pulling out our uh uh unessential
diplomatic personnel um you know from
the situation with zilinski condemned as
you know
demeaning the role of a diplomatic
personnel to this kind of situation that
means keeping them there that means
trying to as to have said negotiate
peace that means some level of
humanitarian or even some level of
military a which may mean weapons or
whatever whatever that is short of
actually having boots on the ground and
projecting the the the aggressive show
of force that the american political
project internationally has projected
for the past 20 plus years anything sort
of that i am okay with but i primarily
want this to be a situation where all
sides come out in peace russia obviously
will not be satisfied until it can
continue its geopolitical expansion
unabated that's what they want and
that's why putin does these military
exercises all around um you know his
area and near finland and everything
because he wants to show that he is
going to be the alpha who will reclaim
the glory of russia and so anything that
you know america or nato even can do to
moderate that and make sure that it's
peacefully resolved i support i still
have the question about the moral
obligation i've seen tonight more
obligations sources and abstractions
america has no obligation to an
abstraction america has an obligation to
its treaties and to its citizens and
those both are very tangible things and
so perhaps if ukraine was in nato that'd
be a different story but regardless it's
been a very good conversation on this
issue going now over to alex stein
wow thank you destiny for staying for my
closing statement i appreciate that okay
and listen guys um i i should have known
uh kevin that you're defending justin
trudeau who's like you know mr blackface
yeah that makes sense you think he's
like handling uh
well i mean but you did say what he's
doing in ukraine is so good so if you're
so against him yet you're going to be a
hypocrite now you're saying he's doing a
great job in the ukraine so that just
shows that you're hypocrite but it
doesn't matter about that it doesn't
matter listen this is what it comes down
to guys it comes down to the military
industrial complex that is influencing
this and you're gonna say oh that
doesn't exist but but guys they're
taking up such a huge uh part of our
budget goes into the military industrial
complex and when you look at it what we
get is the is the juice worth the
squeeze when you look at the vietnam war
when you look at the war in the middle
east ukraine better hope and pray that
we don't come over there and help them
because i promise you i swear to you we
will go up there and mess it up worse
than it already is because what is
happening right now is political theater
putin knows that joe biden is he's about
75 percent there you know what i mean
he's sitting he's he he's just you know
not really in full control so what he's
doing he's playing literal political
theater this is war games and what it's
done is it's it's stirred us up it's got
us debating so it's working it's
distracting us from the real problems
from the idea that we shoot eighty
thousand dollar javelin missiles or shot
by a guy that only makes seventy
thousand dollars a year towards a guy
that doesn't make eighty thousand
dollars in his whole entire life so who
benefits from that scenario the
military-industrial complex and those
are the ones that are encouraging us to
go to the ukrainian border we don't need
to protect ukraine we can't protect them
russia is not going to take them over
they might encroach there to sort of uh
put us in a position and make us look
weak because that's what they want to do
on the world scale but all of this like
i said at the end of the day is just
political theater there's going to be no
bombs america's the only one over to
drop a bomb we're all going to be safe
in our bed we're all going to be able to
stream and get our donations and
speaking of that i got 300 in donations
from oliver tonight thank you oliver i
appreciate that that's my statement i'm
going to now throw it over to adam
something to wrap us up
yeah so first off conspiracy uh
castle it's a nice cat you have by the
way the black and white
thank you i would also be careful
because this is angus
i'd be careful though cats are
controlled by government satellites as
we all know uh real quick i have
toxoplasmosis no adam i don't want to
cut you off but if you're dealing with a
fecal matter it's called toxoplasmosis
crazy catalytic syndrome and i have it
it makes you more like a cat so do not
yes i have toxoplasmosis
let me just clarify something during in
the future during outros and intros you
cannot interrupt anybody's statement or
talk during it just just throw that out
there adam
wait can anybody interrupt
and muted continue
[Laughter]
all right so um yeah so uh to sum up i i
think we're pretty much all in agreement
well most of us anyway about the whole
situation uh there will be no troops on
the ground it seems only in neighboring
nato countries which is fair uh this is
gonna this is going to be a game of
deterrence uh i i personally right now
it looks like russia will not invade
ukraine uh although i might have to eat
grow on this we'll see um
but in case they do that's that will be
a different story then they'll be
embroiled in the in a in a uh
essentially
a in an insurgency war in ukraine um
otherwise the us okay let's just go
through the points so uh
the us i believe does have a more
obligation to help ukraine since you
know they kind of promised and the west
in general nato-land countries did
promise support have been promising
support for eight years uh and now it
would be a bit uh you know
it might le it might leave some bad
taste in some people's mouths to for the
west to to just like say after eight
years well nope sorry you know now that
the now that the heat has been turned uh
turned uh up a bit and then we're like
yeah okay [ __ ] this so that would
actually and that would hurt uh western
geopolitical interest in the long run as
well because our future future
prospective allies against people like
against countries like china russia much
worse places than the west as
imperialistic the west can be uh
countries that might be in the future
aligned with the west as opposed to
china or russia might look at the
ukraine scenario and say oh wait you
know like the second push comes to shop
the west [ __ ] just backs out whatever
you're on your own and i think that
would be devastating geopolitically for
the west in the uh in the future so
let's not wait until it's too late uh
continue supplying weapons that's the
best we can do for now
and if there will be troops on the
ground that will be the troops of other
european uh countries which i think is
completely fair and this is at the end
of the day a european issue in which the
us is heavily involved in so yes that's
my closing statement we should help it's
a good thing that we help
etc
also i'd like to stay before the next
topic i'm seeing a lot of energy in chat
for alex stein versus ctv match uh that
would be an interesting on and and i had
to make one clarify oliver waldis
donated 405 dollars he clarified in the
chat thank you oliver for those
donations
wonderful from oliver okay so we're
gonna go into the next topic for
everybody watching uh this sunday is
movie night on our channel 10 p.m
eastern standard time in the dillon
birds tv discord uh but to keep out all
the unfavorables we will only allow it
for the patreon subs and twitch subs so
we don't let any uh yi scum in there uh
as in you supporters anyway let's go to
the next topic uh the next topic now i'm
actually going to give you guys some
discretion the next topic is supposed to
be about biden's interaction with the
reporter but i wanted to ask you guys
would you rather talk about that or
the new thing that the new news it has
to do with the supreme court and the
supreme court justice resigning what
would be more interesting guys
they're both interesting
i think supreme court might be a little
bit more interesting
it's a little bit more meaty
i'm a well-known expert on the supreme
court of america so yeah we can talk
about the supreme court that's a good
one
supreme court you want that inside of
that okay we'll do the supreme court
then so uh is that the regular court but
with sour cream and tomatoes and lettuce
or is that
yes it's that one that's the okay yeah
okay so
uh a liberal judge
justice breyer after
27 years on the court has decided that
it's time to hang up the gavel at the
ages of
and so soon we will see a fight in
congress a confirmation fight on whether
the supreme court justice that uh joe
biden chooses
after briar uh is gonna get through or
not so my question to all of you is what
do you make of the new supreme court
justice news
and
what do you think
of of biden's upcoming nomination picked
are you excited for him to pick somebody
more to the left you wanted to pick
somebody more moderate what are you
expecting i'm going to start
with uh
parker
okay so i definitely think that biden
should pick someone at least a little
more to the left at least as we saw with
briar but this is definitely something
that we saw coming uh obviously he wants
to um resign at a time in which a
liberal uh can replace him with another
liberal or whatnot so uh it's not really
that surprising so that's really all my
take is right now at least i just want
to hear what other people have to say
okay destiny
um yeah you know i don't i don't know
what more there is say i i hopefully
that he nominates somebody more a little
bit to the left to balance the quote out
a little bit but um i don't know if any
picks have been discussed yet so yeah
it'll be cool what happens okay
uh yes i kept destiny muted so he
couldn't give his opinion on the topics
yet
okay we're gonna throw that over to
taft
yeah i mean i think the progressive wing
the liberals the democrats are worried
about midterms they're worried that
if the senate changes they're not going
to be able to get through their supreme
court picks through
um
and so
yeah they're going to put in a supreme
court pick and biden's promised it to be
a black woman so
probably see that we'll see um
they're definitely vetting lawyers right
now to see who's who's done well
and
i guess i i don't
i don't think it's bad or good
necessarily it's just like the obvious
power politics play and they got breyer
out because
they knew that this was the time to do
it and i know there was previous worry
um
with ruth bader ginsburg people were
pressuring her to retire and she didn't
and
then she got replaced
by a conservative pick so yeah it seems
par for the course for the democrats to
be taking the strategy
dylan is muted
ah sorry i'm gonna throw it over to
christian
yeah so obviously there's not much
controversial about a president picking
the supreme court this is
constitutionally ordained duty what is
particularly egregious about what
happened recently is that biden vowed to
nominate a woman about a black woman to
the supreme court on the basis of her
being black and being a woman now
obviously this was also a campaign
promise he made as well what i find
ridiculous is that he is going to
nominate someone on the baseline
identity to a institution which is not
concerned about identity at all it's
concerned actually um to with the
faithful functions of preserving the
constitution and faithfully adjudicating
the law so what he really is doing is
he's challenging the institution's own
foundational principles by trying to
incorporate his identity politics-based
um pick into the institution which is
dangerous um but also again i think that
it's also bad for the woman who will be
picked because obviously that lady no
matter how qualified she might be
because biden has vowed to pick a black
woman will be seen as a diversity hire
so now you have not only are you
violating the first principles of the
institution the supreme court you're
also castigating the name of the person
by not by not explicitly picking them
for their marriage for identity so it's
an entire cluster f you know what i'm
saying and i think that biden should be
ashamed of himself anyone who's pushing
these ideas should be insured themselves
and that the supreme court should have a
justice liberal or conservative who was
placed there on the basis of their
merits period
wonderful now we're going to throw it
over to
uh kevin castle
yeah thanks dylan so just just a
clarification am i allowed to respond to
the points from the last closing during
the intros to the next topic you are
technically allowed to respond but this
is the final time you could respond to
anything of the last topic yes
gotcha thank you i just want to respond
very quickly just before i go into the
point about briar uh to something that
uh the crazy cat gentleman said he said
something about me uh basically
advocating for
uh
what was it something of the sort of uh
you know that there would be that there
would be war or something or that that
putin was to use nukes against russia or
against the united states i just wanted
to clarify very quickly on that i never
just to be clear here i never
specifically said that putin was
planning to use nukes my whole point was
that in in this particular case that
having uh us troops in ukraine would be
a deterrent against russia going in
there that this is about ukraine that an
american invasion and an invasion of
america would follow if you abandon the
rest of the world it was also about a
moral stance to defend ukraine it's not
imperialist anyway we can move on to
this uh segment so on this segment the
point about the supreme court uh this
might be a little bit of a hot take from
me but
i'm generally pretty center left on
social politics and center right on
economics i i think that for joe biden
some may have been very critical of i
made a video calling him for him to be
impeached after uh he bungled the uh
surrender of the taliban i do think here
that he should actually pick somebody
who is
further to the left than me actually and
i i think that because
the supreme court has been allowed to
skew so far to the right in recent years
under trump that it would it would
naturally be a balance and that what you
would see is that the consequence of
that would be that it would somewhat
counter out to be closer to where i'm at
generally speaking and where
similarly-minded folks to me are
and the way that you counter that is to
actually pick somebody who's further to
the left than me so that there's even
less of a debate over you know which
side are they going to go with or
whatnot in the court i mean if i could
have it my way i'd like to see him also
pick an atheist but that's that's
probably not going to happen but i don't
i don't have an issue i'll say this i
don't have an issue with him explicitly
stating uh joe biden explicitly stating
that
he's nominating somebody and
specifically mentioning the
characteristics that he's looking for
because you could say joe biden goes to
pick a set of nominees and he decides
that he's going to pick a a a black
woman to do it uh from a various array
of people of different uh skin color
backgrounds etc well you could say well
he arrived at the same thing i actually
i think i think it was better for him to
do it this way because what he's doing
is he's setting a a message that there
has historically been a lack of
opportunity in uh
in the supreme court for uh women of
color and this is him trying to counter
that out so this is a w for joe biden
and i hope he moves very quickly with
this because he's not going to have
forever thank you okay
now i'm going to throw it over to
alex stein
i'm not just a crazy cat lady i'm also a
crazy dog lady so i wanted that i want
that to be known um yes the supreme
court justice this is the problem with
intersectionality if we pick somebody
based on just the color of their skin
it's not based on merits if somebody
gets somebody theoretically it could be
more qualified that gets passed over so
i think that that's bad but really at
the end of the day left right amy coney
barrett's i mean she she acts like she's
so conservative she votes a lot to the
left so really it's like and these
politicians what they do is
they urinate on us and they tell us it's
raining it doesn't matter who's in power
they all do the same thing
thank you very much
that's what that was so we're gonna
throw it over to adam
right so well this is a very much
american issue and as a european i don't
have that much insight into it uh well
with that just to inject some maybe
unrelated nuance to the situation like i
from like from a european perspective
progressive american progressive
candidates like left candidates right
candidates from europe it's all right
wing essentially uh the us is much more
to the right than europe in general
uh bernie sanders's wildest fever dreams
are a monday in most european countries
uh and so if biden picks uh uh some like
i don't know uh african-american woman
to be the supreme court justice then
that's fine i can i can see is the
discussion going into affirmative action
from this
but i mean hey it's americans i'm sure
biden will pick the candidate and then
burgers will be heads and the wwe match
and that's going to be the end of it
wonderful that's that's my very valuable
insight to the situation it's kind of
racist my mom was a professional
wrestler so that's not that's rude my
mom my knees as well
and she's a prostitute so are you
against prostitutes well mine isn't okay
so
let's continue i'm gonna throw it now
over to
destiny
um i could see it going either way i
don't think that um i don't think it's
necessarily the worst thing in the world
to preemptively announce i guess like
the makeup of a judge because i think
you could potentially argue that part of
the function of the supreme court is to
represent uh maybe the united states so
having an all-white all-male or all
black all-female or whatever type of
court might not be as representative of
our country as we would want an
important branch of government to be so
i don't think it's the worst thing in
the world just hopefully the pick is a
good pick that could stand on their own
merits and it isn't somebody that seems
uniquely unqualified for the job
okay next i'm going to throw it over to
pixel
um i think it's interesting when we're
talking about diversity higher when uh
basically trump's
idea of the diversity higher was amy
connor coney barrett um who is
definitely not on the goddamn lift by
the way um just to clarify um
but i think it's
uh not a bad thing that the supreme
court becomes more representative of the
american population in general i think
there are a lot of
in my expertise as an australian i think
there are a lot of um holes in the way
that the supreme court functions now and
i think that any
person who could be nominated who could
potentially stand up against probably
the upcoming uh
discussion about roe v wade again uh
would be a really good thing for women
um so
yeah i think
hopefully it's somebody more to the left
um
but i think it's going to depend on who
biden thinks he can sell
to the majority of people voting in the
senate or approving in the senate if
that makes sense okay i think
everybody's spoken
um okay then we're going to start
oh wait
um watson did you not
speak
i thought you were like
i have something to say though i have to
say that yes i spoke okay so you can you
can start it austin
yeah yeah so you know this argument uh
that you know that destiny put out what
has really been put out for a long while
recently wrote about it that the supreme
court should look more like america is
an argument that really confuses me for
a few reasons um number one looking what
it means to look like america is quite
unquantifiable you can look at general
geographic trends and statistics and say
okay america is going this way therefore
you would look more like america if you
did this problem is there are a lot of
states in america and there are a lot of
states in america that may not
necessarily reflect the general
geographic checks because general
geographic trends are indeed general so
how do you really quantify that you
can't and really what value what
epistemic value do you give an
institution because really the supreme
court congress businesses any
institution that people want to look
like america the their concern with
episodic value which basically means
they're concerned with having knowledge
that can allow them to function properly
the supreme court is concerned with
having knowledgeable people on their on
their uh on their justice board that
will allow them to function according to
their proper functions
there is no epistemic value to having
people on the supreme court for the sake
of diversity now i will say this
but um trump and reagan
both vow to nominate women and guess
what as someone himself who is
conservative and someone who has a
decent admiration for reagan much less
for trump i think that was a wrong
decision not not because they nominated
a woman but because they vowed
explicitly to nominate a woman instead
of nominating the best qualified
candidate so whether it comes from the
left or the right identity politics is
always an epistemic pit that gives us
nothing to our institutions which does
not allow us to adhere to first
principles and certainly does not not
add anything of merit to the functions
of institutions i
i mean frankly when it comes to the
supreme court as long as they're
qualified it's fine um
it's only going to be an issue if like
you're unable to find qualified supreme
court justices who supreme court picks
that aren't black women but there's
there are great candidates who are black
women so i don't think that is
necessarily a big problem in this
scenario
my only concern would be that like if
you know you're setting a model or a
precedent about what is acceptable
behavior and there are other
environments you know most other
environments i would say where
hiring someone purely based on the color
of their skin
or vowing to do that is not appropriate
and
it's really a very it's a special
environment where you're hiring only one
person and where there has been
precedent previously for
making sure the supreme court you know
has some diversity
well look look i i think that look it's
totally fine i'm not saying that it's
not okay to have a black hole on the
supreme court what i'm saying it is
wrong to have that as the prefix to uh
looking at a qualified candidate because
again you are whittling down the the
pool and you are kind of reducing maybe
not totally but you are kind of reducing
that individual to their identity
features which would you know which is
what biden precisely is doing and here's
the idea the underlying idea is this the
underlying idea is that because black
women have supposedly not been
represented in many industries in
america we have to take the equitable
decision and incorporate them in their
and and their um presence into more
institutions to remedy that injustice
well the problem with that is you don't
actually do that for all black women
because not all black women are impacted
by one thing you know there are a lot of
black women who are not lawyers and will
never be on the supreme court so how in
the world are you helping them by
putting a black lady on the supreme
court you're not we should stop speaking
in abstractions and look at
qualifications and stop using
victimology as a as a criteria by which
to order our institution because the
moment we do that is the moment our
first principles erupt and our
institutions fall down and they die i
think that's important when we look at
it
i think that when we look at the
composition of the supreme court i think
from a first principal's point of view i
think it can be important that the
members of the supreme court seem
relatively representative in general of
the united states population i think why
if we wanted to attack um sure because
the united states population in part
draws its rule of law or how laws are
interpreted the constitution directly
from the supreme court and i think that
if you have a country that's being
that's getting their most important
legal document interpreted by a bench
that doesn't look anything like them or
isn't anything like them i think that
reasonably large swaths of americans can
feel like hmm i don't really feel like
this whole body of government doesn't it
doesn't represent me very well right if
you're a woman and there's a and nine
men are about to make the decision on
whether or not roe v wade stays as law i
think that you can rightfully feel like
my government doesn't represent me and
when we're living in a representative
democracy i think it's fair to point to
that as an important epistemic value of
the core that where people derive their
truth could come from their subjective
experience which if you read any court
briefs or how people especially scalia
right would write you know that the
decisions that these justices make are
oftentimes very personal they're not
these arbiters these logic lords or
whatever like they very much draw on
personal experiences to make some of
these decisions well after the warren
court has certainly done a lot of damage
to the integrity of the supreme court
and and even before the war in court
there are a lot of problems with the
supreme court as well so i'm not going
to pretend that the supreme court
justices are arbiters of truth or
arbiters of of moral principles although
they should be and if you look at
marbury versus madison instead of citing
a bunch of case law because there really
wasn't any at least not in america
because the first supreme court case
judicial review there was a lot of
philosophy cited so maybe the course get
back to philosophy instead of acting you
know as as this sort of a body of
destructive opinions but another thing
you mentioned you mean something called
standpoint epistemology and standpoint
epistemology is this idea that what is
true is true to me because i experienced
it or i have experiences with it so
there are certain troops that i as a
black man can't access um that a black
woman or an asian woman can access that
standpoint of epistemology the idea with
this is that knowledge is not based
solely on our experiences um knowledge
is is uh as kant said and he eventually
went on to argue his persons but he said
that all knowledge uh arises from
experience oh no excuse me all knowledge
begins from experience not all knowledge
arises from experience and that's the
correct and then lock took that idea and
he made sort of his empirical model of
the world there is a world that exists
outside of our experience that we can
observe and we can extract natural
truths from so because i am a black man
is not necessarily mean i have
experienced a certain amount of things
that a white man hasn't there are white
people who have experienced the things
that i have not have experienced i never
lived in trailer park before i never
lived in appalachian before i've never
been dirt poor image in the trailer
before so there are plenty of white
folks who have experienced that so i
don't understand what do you mean how do
you represent a black person what does
that mean destiny how do you do what so
i don't think this is necessarily
related to standpoint epistemology i
think that it's a more general uh
explanation it is that it's we're not
doing a crt discussion i promise okay i
think that gender no it's not about crt
it's not about crt
i think that generally it's fair to say
that a person's subjective experience
can color if you will uh how they might
view the world i think it's fair to say
that women probably have unique
experiences in the united states or in
the world that are different from men
that black people or asian people or
hispanic people or different types of
black people different types of people
probably have experiences in the united
states that might be slightly different
than other groups of people and having
that sort of representation on the court
much like we like our jury to be
representative of the communities we
live in probably has some value to it at
the very least so that a democratic
people feel like they're being ruled by
people like them well this becomes a
majoritarian problem then because if you
have like nine phyllis schlafly and for
those of you who don't know phil
schlafly was a very uber conservative
activist who fought against the correct
women back in the 70s or 80s you have
nine phyllis schlafly's on the supreme
court it's a woman but a lot of women
probably wouldn't like that because
phyllis schlafly didn't think that women
she'd like that woman should be barefoot
pregnant and they should be in the
household but she's a woman so this is
this is the point
you know your identity does not
necessarily give you uh this uh a
particular set point of view and this is
the idea but then deposits
horrendous argument hold on you
understand that because i'm not saying
that would you acknowledge or do you
live in a fantasy land that different
identities in general have different
experiences in the united states
identities don't have experiences people
have experiences so i reject the premise
outright in the beginning okay so you
don't believe that any large analysis of
a people is possible you can only look
at no i didn't say that
in general
wait wait destiny you asked him a
question you got to let him clear yes
you ask questions then you then you move
away let me answer so general
qualitative you know uh analysis that
people people uh sociologists do they
have a place although i'm very uh i'm
very uh critical of qualitative analysis
typically because they don't necessarily
rely too much on you know what is hardly
what is observed through quantitative
analysis i think both are obviously
necessary but i think quantitative if
we're going to be making any sort of uh
a general general idea general
predictions excuse me i can't talk to
that um then we should probably look at
quantitative analysis but yeah no
qualitative analysis absolutely does
have a place sure why not do you think
there are patriarchal influences that
exist oh sorry we gotta let justin
respond where and then sorry hold on i'm
gonna since i see the strategy
you're going to do your thing right so
the strategy is to constantly duck and
evade the obvious point and answer the
most obviously possible so it seems like
yes so it's going to give a reason the
strategy is
okay so the obvious answer to anybody
with two eyes that looks around them in
the world is that different groups of
people tend to have different types of
experiences that's why that if you as a
black man are charged with murder or
charged with raping a white woman and
then you go to jail and your juror are
nine white women and you're from alabama
you might think hey this feels a little
bit [ __ ] up 99 people in that
situation wouldn't go ah well you know
these nine women you know it is possible
that all of them are marching with blm
and now they've come to sit on my court
obviously we can speak in broad
generalities about how different groups
of people have different experiences in
the united states this is why broadly
speaking people around the world like to
be represented by people like them
whether we're talking about football and
we like to see different countries
represented in the world cup whether
we're talking about a jury of our peers
if we want to look like us whether we're
talking about the makeup of congress
whether we're talking about the
community police to police us in general
people like to feel like they're being
represented in a representative
democracy so i think it's fair to say
that the composition of a court probably
should be roughly similar or attempt at
least to match the composition of the
people uh holding all things equal we
still want them to be qualified
candidates of course i think that if
there was one attack you wanted to make
on the supreme court one horrible thing
that we've done to the supreme court
that i think is by far the most damaging
thing we've done in the supreme court is
when we start to pick supreme court
justices that lean left or lean right i
think that that is the most damaging
thing we've ever done way before we get
into identity politics or anything else
i think that is the most damaging thing
we've done to the court when we've tried
to balance it with liberals and
conservatives that is ridiculous to me
okay i got a lot before before
there's like six people on the list to
talk and don't worry you're about to
talk again because pixel was going to
answer your ask you a question
yeah i was just curious if you think
that there are patriarchal influences
that filter down through the american
democratic system right now and if any
sort of like push back towards that for
representation um for women was a
particularly important thing to you
well define patriarchal what do you mean
like like in whatever okay
here's my here's my deal
yes obviously
there have been ins there have been
assistant american history where women
have not been given a fair shake i'm not
going to deny that that's very uh very
obvious that's why we had people like
student b anthony fought for women's
ability women's suffrage although i
think that any kind of suffrage this is
where my my sort of libertarian leanings
come in any kind of quote-unquote
suffrage is nonsensical and immoral
because you really cannot you cannot
create virtuous outcomes by force and
what the government really is is force
that's a different situation uh but no i
i they're absolutely well you can think
it's cringe all you want but that's not
an argument so this there are actually
instances about american history where
absolutely women have given been given a
fair shake but i think the fair shake
has more so happened socially yes you're
correct there was a sort of uh dominance
of of men especially back in the 50s and
60s even really before the sexual
revolution um you know over the
household and we can absolutely analyze
that from a social viewpoint and see if
that was bad or not i think any ideology
that tries to restrict the agency of
someone because of what they look like
is bad and yes there have been
patriarchy in america that has done that
but do i think the fact that this that
the institutions that america have been
historically run by men is inherently
patriarchal no because
men are the subjects of patriarchy but
patriarchy is more than simply a man
being in control so that's the problem
with these sort of third-wave feminist
ideas because they're not really
feminists they're misandrists they
actually hate men and they want to do
everything they can to to bring the id
the the idea of men down including
casting them
not my idea of feminism i'm not saying
yours i'm saying third way
people are just looking for a far more
intersectional representation of like
ideas and beliefs that exist in america
and if you are like patriotic and
believe in the democracy that has been
created by america we should be pushing
for more equal representation because i
don't believe in democracy
america america is not democracy
i i don't believe in democracy i don't
believe in democracy yeah libertarian
doesn't believe in democracy who would i
believe
no i don't why are you a libertarian
what do you believe in the libertarian
with the best was it new hampshire was
it the bear colin was it the best what
wasn't there
wasn't there a libertarian colony in
america somewhere but it didn't last
very long because the bears came in no i
mean
okay i don't i don't know i mean there's
a lot of libertarianism
there's a lot of libertarian pop-ups of
course it is of course there's
libertarianism libertarian about the
idea of the supreme court if you're a
libertarian
because i have to do i have to deal with
practical circumstances and a lot of
folks think that libertarians are not
the prodigal stuff we do i have to do a
practical circumstance at least i do as
someone who is interested in philosophy
and who actually wants to help the
american experiment get better and
better and better i have to deal with
practical circumstances and in my
opinion trying to distort the image of
the supreme court by injecting equity
and diversity and inclusion into the
supreme court is going to hurt the
american experiment so i have a more
obligation to stand up for this for well
that's the support for the american
experiment in the form of that kind of
resistance righteous
version of america is rooted in not the
1950s but probably at the 1850s at this
level
jesus what moral opposition would you
have had like
again we saw this in the previous
segment where you you couldn't tell that
uh that moral action was needed to be
taken against russia what moral argument
would you have against the abolitionist
slavery then because the logical
conclusion of what you're arguing and
i've got a question for you as well
you're comparing the supreme court
justices
everybody please let kevin finish asking
the black person why it'd be against
slavery continue
yeah no i'm just
it's no it's it's a simple question it's
a simple uh a question that i have
basically which is that you've said that
you're against democracy you've said
that suffrage would be forcing people to
have rights and you've also said that
you're opposed to injecting equity
and whatnot into the supreme court the
world that you're laying out
is a very reactionary vision of america
that's not shared by most americans and
not in the direction that america is
moving and i i think that the the
founding fathers of america ultimately
envisioned a self-perfecting system that
they knew that they were flawed from the
outset and it seems like you want to
keep a lot of these flaws and maintain
their sort of institutionalization my
question for you christian is very
simple which is that
you said in your intro you said that uh
that you felt that what does this do for
everybody who's black or everybody who's
a woman because you said that that not
everybody who meets those
characteristics is in the judiciary but
you acknowledge it was almost implicit
in your acknowledgment there that this
would be helpful or could be seen as
helpful if you are black and a woman and
you're in law so i guess my question is
your logic seems to be
because we can only kind of solve one
thing a little bit here that only
affects a few people and we can't do
everything at the same time at once
therefore do nothing my question to you
is do you actually genuinely want to
help people that are historically
disadvantaged or is it almost concerned
trolling i guess is what i meant oh my
jesus so what you're doing there is
first of all you equivocated so there is
no there is no there is absolutely no
similarity between the abolition of
slavery which was a righteous cause
final on the principle of natural law
and the idea of having a black woman in
the supreme court or in the corporate
boardroom there is absolutely no
relationship to me that seems to be very
clear between those two putting people
in bondage against their rights is a
violation of their natural rights and
that's something that obviously every
moral person should respond to putting a
black woman in an institution to say
that you are now representing people
when in our reality there is no one
person of any group that represents
anyone of that group that is not the
same thing and that is an absurdity and
that is my point i want to help people
who have been quote unquote historically
disadvantaged by allowing us to have a
merit to crack a colorblind system that
does not take into account their
identity or their race but takes into
account what they can do the problem is
and this is what w.e.b du bois said in
this all black folk the problem has
never been that black folks have been
unqualified w.e.b dubois said that the
black race would be saved by its best he
said the negro race would be saved by
its best men the problem is their merits
have not been historically in a lot of
places historically um not been
acknowledged by the broader system or
they have been forcibly suppressed by
the bodybutter system so what do you do
you change that not by trying to do a
sort of reverse type of thing where you
look at their skin color and above their
merits and then put them in positions
but you change that by looking blindly
at their merits and you do that by
embracing a colorblind system that does
not embrace diversity equity or
inclusion you are presuming that ddi or
you know having this sort of equitable
mindset is the only way to correct
historical injustice and that is
absolutely not not correct so i think
that your argument is just absolute well
then
your argument acts your argument one
second
your argument acts that this is the only
way because you have been saying well
you don't want to do this or that so you
must want to help people no i don't want
to buy into the system i want to buy
into the false paradigm that says these
are the ways we have to address these
issues there are ways that are not um
protect potentially orthodox that we can
use to address these issues that embrace
the spirit of radical individualism that
are founded upon the american system so
you you'd have to actually lay out an
alternative way then as opposed to just
getting abstract i just did it because i
just said earlier well no you haven't
you said earlier that you that you
opposed suffrage and then you thought
that suffrage was wrong but yeah you're
trying to play but you're trying to tell
me about that that the abolition of
slavery was justified but in most of
those cases you're using force to
emancipate people though so yeah rounds
because it kind of sounds like you're an
advocate of the literal patriarchy at
this point is what it sounds like no no
no no no no no so again you're you're
after all either
though chris after christian response we
gotta go to other people on the list uh
christian students like 40 of this topic
so just other people sure understood and
that my apologies so again you're
drawing together a bunch of things we're
not necessarily related me being me
being opposed to equity does not mean
i'm in favor of the patriarchy there's
no relation between the two of me being
opposed to the idea me being opposed to
suffrage is also not being in favor of
the patriarchy either by the way because
the suffrage has been used quote unquote
by the patriarchy to advance their
causes too so it's a sort of all-purpose
tool isn't it so the idea of suffrage
i'm against it and my one of my favorite
philosophers like senator spooner wrote
an essay about this uh and what she
basically says there's nothing wrong
with women and they have natural rights
but there's something wrong with
thinking you can affect moral change
through an inherently immoral system and
that immoral system is voting and so and
it's in voting is immoral because it
utilizes force many times illegitimately
now this is where i don't agree with
spooner's argument he would have the
entire government
no no no no no no no i'm trying to
qualify you'd have the entire government
abolished i wouldn't but a lot of times
in the current era even back then
government is involved in areas where it
has no more right to be and when you and
when voting is a thing it can allow
people to affect those areas and further
entrench government involvement so
that's why i'm against this idea of
suffrage and as a right per se not
against the idea of voting in principle
i think that it's a privilege i think
that it's important to a republic to be
able to vote but it's not necessarily a
sacred right that allows us to be
virtuous to make good moral decisions or
be good citizens not necessarily so
that's my opinion i want to talk to you
for too long but it's a very nuanced
idea i have and no i'm not in support of
hr because i don't think that voting is
right
i think that if you had a system where
all the supreme court justices 100 of
them were from san francisco that would
be a problem
and it's not because everyone from san
francisco necessarily has the same
opinions the same experiences and so on
but we can agree there's a broader trend
right and the people in san francisco
are going to tend to have a kind of
experience that is not necessarily
shared across the rest of the country so
when we're talking about government
systems i don't think it's crazy to try
to appoint supreme court justices that
are representative of a diversity of
opinions and experiences right this is
like one of the
one of the situations where it
absolutely does make sense to look for a
diversity of experiences right and like
i'm listening to you kristin and i agree
about
these like
policies that are putting the skin color
first and are making people feel like
diversity hires like i've been in that
position and it sucks to feel that way
right
and it's not fun and i don't think it's
good generally but i think maybe we can
come to some common ground and i think
the san francisco example is a good
example because i think if the supreme
court was 100 people from new york new
york you probably also wouldn't like
that and you'd probably also want some
diversity of viewpoint and experience in
that in that environment
yeah the problem with the diversity
higher line though let's just be clear
about it
[Music]
oh okay
is it my turn i said yes adam it is your
turn okay thank you to get in here right
so um
with regards to a point whether
institutions should like should
represent the people uh as uh divided
by the administration is trying to do uh
the answer is yes and i can even give
you european examples from my good old
home country hungary back uh in central
europe there there's a sort of national
pastime called uh
majoritarianism
meaning that the dominant group uh the
dominant ethnic group uh culturally and
uh population wise they get to rule
everything and no one else gets
represented now uh this actually led to
uh essentially the the quick dissolution
of hungary in the end after the triune
treaties uh losing two-thirds of its
territories but only because
everything was in hungarian hungarians
were in charge they were 48 of the total
population and you know the rest
basically could just go get go [ __ ]
themselves so there's a very good case
to be made to for making
um institutions representative of the
people it contributes to essentially
national stability
uh also
there are points made about like
meritocracy and uh basically just let
let the essentially the free market you
know the big meme uh let the feeder
market decide uh like well
yeah uh this is not i i know this is not
really the point what you but like the
idea of meritocracy i just wanted to
clarify that
our current system has its own like our
current system but by that i'm talking
about the us so the u.s system has its
own baggage at this point so certain
people through historic injustices have
collected or lost wealth there is now a
high wealth hierarchy i think what was
it like for every 100 person
every hundred dollars a white
family owns there's like 2.50 for like a
black family or something so there's
very clear very very clear uh uh
differences between different people men
and women there's there's also like
there's the pay gap and et cetera
if you go like these for you to advocate
for meritocracy first you need to
equalize these things uh and then we're
getting into the weeds of like okay
implicit bias etc which might against
skewed results my point is currently the
idea of meritocracy in the us is a myth
uh it cannot function by definition
because in a meritocracy if everyone
just gets if everyone just gets the same
amount of of uh
of starting
uh uh i guess political power or capital
or whatever with our with the us's
current baggage socio-economic baggage
they'll just end up reinforcing existing
hierarchies in in a pretty short term
basically
uh yeah so that's that's for now i'm
done so i'll join in later in the
discussion
okay um
i think that's everybody on the list
does do oh kevin it looks like you have
your hand raised
yeah well i just wanted to say i just
wanted to clarify something very quickly
just about the diversity higher thing i
think that the diversity higher line is
it's kind of uh
it's kind of uh unfortunate here because
what biden's saying is that he's going
to be picking somebody who meets the
characteristics of being black and
female but he's not saying that he's
doing that and and thereby saying well
other other people are better or like
the assumption in saying that somebody's
a diversity higher automatically means
that you think well they only got this
job because of their skin color or
whatever it's very possible that if you
were to have say a hundred different
candidates selected no criteria enforced
that you wind up with a black woman and
be on the supreme court what he's doing
here isn't saying well there's no way
that they could get this without me
explicitly stating it he's not doing
that what he's doing here is a symbol
rather of
an acknowledgement of historical
disadvantage
which everybody here seems to
acknowledge was the case and he's saying
we're attempting to rectify that so when
people say oh you they're just a
diversity hire it ultimately uh it
assumes that the only reason why they
got this job uh is that they would have
lost out if they were in an open pool
it's very well that a black woman could
have won in an open pool what he's doing
here is sending a message though and i
actually i i support it and i also will
say
just to clarify here the reason why he
needs to pick somebody as well that's to
the left of me is that the republicans
have had three people that are
considerably to the right of where i'm
at and so me looking at this
why wouldn't the democrats also follow
suit in that i know destiny said that um
that the problem with the u.s supreme
court was that it got politicized but
destiny you'd still say that the
democrats would be right to pick
somebody as a liberal you would you say
that if you're somebody yeah you have to
play the game they're playing of course
unfortunately yeah
yeah like it's a problem that it started
out that way but now that that's the
role of the game biden would be a fool
not to counter that right so
so i that those are just my thoughts on
this situation obviously i got a lot of
criticisms of joe biden and everything
but it seems kind of goofy to to be
particularly upset that biden decided
that he's going to pick somebody who's a
black female like what what's he going
to do come out and say i'm going to pick
a white male like that would be weird
by doing that he's excluding he's
excluding gay people he's excluding
trans people he's excluding a lot of
other people
are marginalized as well i'm just saying
there's other marginalized people that
he's excluding that could be represented
so by him saying a black person and
black women are very uh marginalized in
society they're not
they're not they're not the most
marginalized people though i'm just
saying there's other people so so what
but why not a hispanic why not a
filipino there's a america's a melting
pot i'm saying why does it have to be a
black woman do you see what i'm saying
i think that's the problem i think for
the first time in this debate conspiracy
castle's making some sense um he's
correct from the left
that's right well
from the left there is this sort of
intersectional hierarchy that says that
the more intersectional the more your
identity is intersects with oppression
the more oppressed you are and therefore
the more equity you need okay if that's
the case then being black and a woman
those are two categories according to a
lot of left-wing ideology that do
intersect with certain kinds of
oppression but if you're a black well if
you're black if you're a woman if you're
obese and if you're trans or well yeah
you're trans woman rather you have more
identities if you're disabled more so
again there could be a critique from the
left saying why isn't biden including
more identities in that and i'm certain
there are critics going to laugh about
that too um but the general no
no no no one is seriously making that
criticism though maybe perhaps not but
it's one that can be it's one if you
believe in intersectionality absolutely
speaking at once um
christian you can finish your point and
then we gotta wrap up okay
okay okay here's my general point about
this okay so
i have no problem with a black woman
being on the supreme court there are
plenty of black women who are
conservative jurists or who have not
even always even voted with the
conservative side um you know who i mean
barack obama i forgot who she's a woman
in arizona i forgot what her name was
but barack obama when he was a senator
accused her of being a judicial activist
barack obama accusing someone of being a
jedi activist and he goes on and
appoints some of the biggest activists
in the court's history which is
interesting so but there are plenty of
qualified women um black women that
biden could absolutely pick who are not
or conservative but the problem is it's
not just about them being a black woman
it's about them being a black woman
who's also progressive and in my opinion
you should not have the identity
identity qualifier uh at the forefront
of a consideration that is going to
impact an institution which is crucial
to preserving and adjudicating the
constitution which is the document upon
which the american political project
rests that's what i'm saying identity
has no relation to that whatsoever and
and i and i don't care who i don't care
if people think that if someone is black
and they're black they have a
relationship within the sort of
metaphysical relationship it's nonsense
i don't have a metaphysical relationship
with someone just because they're black
i don't know them i have nothing in
common with them regardless of our skin
color i'm not in common with them i
can sort with people but no the argument
is that people want to feel represented
and having someone who's black might
make black folks feel more
representative that's nonsense though
because i'm not necessarily represented
just because someone is black if i have
nothing in common with them i don't
share values with them that does not
mean i'll be represented i mean if louis
farrakhan became a big political figure
he's black but i don't agree with
anything man says so skin colors
literally no one is
you guys are like that america should
have people of different experiences
different beliefs i agree but you seem
to be aligning that with skin color or
some kind of other identity gender or
whatever because
one identity that you wouldn't live in
life you're also not
[Music]
could you finish your question then
watson will have like 20 seconds respond
we gotta wrap up
it seems like you're ignoring the fact
that there has always been an underlying
identity qualifier for the supreme court
in the first place which was that you
were a white man at the start right like
and that kind of idea has filtered down
through the system so like the idea of
identity qualifiers has always been
there except now it's a little bit
different and it's trying to be more
representative of a population in
general
and as i mentioned instead of embracing
the reverse of the original wretched
idea of using identity as a qualifier
for someone you ought to reject it
outright and embrace colorblindness full
stop that's all i'll say about this
you ever think there's a scenario
okay
we'll move on it's kind of funny that
nine white people are telling a black
guy about culture representation okay
we're gonna know
okay
okay
so now we're gonna do wrap up can you do
me too
yes gladly and i'll definitely so now
we're gonna throw it over to taft
wrapping up i don't think it's crazy to
try to have your supreme court represent
the people and
i think if there's any scenario in which
there is some legitimacy in
trying to hire a diversity of opinions
and appoint them it would be a scenario
like the supreme court there are
legitimate criticisms of engaging in
diversity hiring and i think that those
are much more true elsewhere i've
personally experienced this and it sucks
but
it makes sense to me in this scenario
and obviously there's a political game
being played here and the democrats are
going to try to get in a liberal supreme
court justice and that's just
the way way it goes the way that
politics are right now
okay i'm gonna throw it over to kevin
castle
yeah thanks dylan so uh i'll just start
by saying you know i hope i i don't
think he will but i i hope that biden
doesn't uh replicate uh uh obama's sort
of uh hesitation with uh with uh
nominating a supreme court justice and
and fall for any sort of republican uh
delusions about bipartisanship here
everybody knows that the supreme court
has become a political institution at
this point and all that you can do if
you're a democratic president in that
context is to you know appoint somebody
who's very uh democrat very left within
the american context and rush them
through i i really do hope that he
rushes them through i think that a
balance is important especially given
that you've got three new uh
conservative justices i think that
that's important that's why i say i hope
he goes for somebody who's still left of
where i am to counter that out you know
uh i'll say this as well
i actually i i like uh the ideal of
colorblindness i'm not like a big fan of
crt or anything i've argued against that
kind of stuff in the past but but the
thing is the thing is there's a little
bit of a nuance with my position on this
which is that
well we're not there yet we're not there
yet in america and we're not there yet
in canada in canada we've had injustices
against uh indigenous people for example
that's happening in the united states
too and there's been injustices against
uh black women
in general in the united states
specifically in the judiciary and i
think that the goal that you want to get
to down the road is where you can have a
fair colorblind system but in order to
get there you have to rectify previous
imbalances and i think that this is a
step in that direction i do think though
that once that sort of equity is reached
that you can actually have a serious and
genuine colorblind approach so in that
sense i believe in that sort of liberal
colorblind approach that a lot of people
criticize but the leftists on the panel
so far have made a very good argument
and compelling argument and in general
on social media i've seen leftists make
a better argument on this issue than
conservatives right now because the fact
of the matter is america's not ready to
have a genuine
fair colorblind approach on this
you actually have to rectify for
previous imbalances first to get there
uh so
uh to get outraged by this is
it's pretty cringey honestly and i think
that uh joe biden's i hope he hires
somebody very good very qualified for
the position and they may he was going
to dismiss them as oh they're diversely
high or whatever no there's somebody
very qualified who happened to also just
meet the characteristics that were
desired there thank you gonna throw it
over the pixel
i agree with the canadian centrist i i
think most of those points were pretty
solid um
i also think that america is in a very
difficult spot because politics has
gotten to this place where
uh it's such a team sport including
things like supreme court hires they
have become a team sport i'm going to
nominate somebody who represents my team
rather than somebody who represents like
uh my ideology um specifically so i hope
that joe biden nominates somebody even
to the left of him um and i i hope that
he uh
does exactly what donald trump did and
push and pushes somebody through before
midterms because
roe v wade is um i worry about the
government's position on roe v wade uh
for women in america i think it's really
concerning so
yeah i'm gonna throw it over to parker
so i don't think it's the worst thing in
the world to base upon our base like who
we pick for the supreme court based upon
like allowing for more equitable
representation i think that's generally
a decent thing to do
i also don't think that we can just like
ignore the fact that um who's
determining who has the most merit and
who's the best option for like uh for
like the supreme court or not in the
legislative branch we're talking about
senate or whatnot we're talking about
it's overwhelmingly men it's
overwhelmingly white we know who is
picking these type of people that are
going to the supreme court so we also
have to take that into account when we
are uh adopting people to the supreme
court i don't think it's necessarily the
best thing to say like oh we should look
for like a person of this specific
characteristic but i do think that we do
have to take into account injustice of
the past uh to allow for more
representation amongst like our systems
of power
okay i'm gonna throw it over now to
destiny
um
yeah i mean i'm just echoing everything
that's already been said i think that
representation among our political
institutions is pretty important when we
are ruled democratically we want to feel
like those institutions represent us um
if i had a panel of you know like nine
uh asian people deciding whether or not
affirmative action should exist at a
school or nine you know whatever uh
women deciding whether or not paternal
rights should be protected for children
or whatever like i think it's i think
it's good in our systems in general to
have some representation of the general
population so that they feel like their
institutions represent them when it
comes time to ruling on how those
institutions uh are how they engage with
those institutions
okay i'm gonna now throw it over to adam
something
thank you so uh i mean yes i pretty much
agree to what destiny said uh there is
by the way a a uh a meritocratic case
for affirmative action uh
because if you take a uh black and white
person have similar achievements but the
black person
is uh is like a bit lower of course uh
but the black person comes from a very
impoverished background because
historically of course black people have
been more reported in the u.s and this
tends to reason that the black person
worked much harder to get to that level
below the somewhat somewhere below the
white person and so at that point uh you
know the person who worked the uh the
hardest should get the position so
there's that
uh but i don't i'm not i'm not looking
to open an argument on that i just want
to put it out there as for the
meritocracy argument of course as people
said you know meritocracy at this point
cannot work yet it's a nice future
prospect
but it's it's the same way as like it's
as if you you you instituted like
limitless free market in the us tomorrow
by just like removing the government
uh yeah that's cool but but uh then you
know two days later you're gonna be
living in the bezos empire because uh
you know because of all his leverage and
because of all the advantage he built up
which he will leverage of course in
pursuit of power so
yeah that's my take
he wouldn't have subsidies anymore the
christian
you're next
i guess
anyway yeah so look i think that it's
quite a it's quite obvious what the
answer is here if you're going to if
you're looking at this from a first
principles foundational perspective on
the american experiment um and you guys
can laugh all you want but the but the
answer here is very simple we pick
someone who is concerned with executing
the the functions faithfully of the
supreme court and you pick someone who
is concerned with doing that and not
someone on the basis of what they look
like or what you presume their
experience to be because they're a black
woman or whatever consortium of
identities you've managed to concoct and
you're in your paradigm you know the
supreme court has a very particular duty
in the united states it's very
particular duty to its institutions and
we should have an eye on preserving
those and not preserving our ideas of
what they should look like when those
ideas may not add anything that is
epistemically beneficial to the
institutions themselves
and alex
well guys it's been a lovely debate i
have to say you know is very spirited at
times and listen we know that joe biden
is the most popular president ever 81
million votes so we know that he is a
great representation and joe biden we
know that is one of the best presidents
of all time that we know that he is so
capable and that he's running this
country he's doing an awesome job so
with the job that he's doing because
america is
doing so great right now i can't wait
for the supreme court justice that he
picks as a matter of fact like i said i
love the intersex sectionality aspect of
it i'm just mad that it's not
representative enough of people that are
marginalized like i said i would like to
see a trans person somebody gender fluid
i would like to see more people that are
marginalized represented but we know
that joe is the smartest guy his son
hunter biden even said is the smartest
person he knows i hope he asks hunter i
hope he asks his son i hope they i hope
he calls hunter on the phone they smoke
some crack together and they they figure
out who this is going to be because let
me tell you something if joe biden is
doing he's doing such a good job with
america right now i know whoever he
picks is going to be uh
the best thing for america
yeah the main point is that they're not
going to be a certain ethnic group right
i know i hope they're part i hope
they're black and gay and trans no i
hope they're part of everything
with the echo and the deep state we got
it we gotta we gotta keep going okay
uh for everybody at home of course
donation subs and everything to keep the
show going is appreciated uh and i think
again everybody for coming on for the
for the show i know it's a long one but
we only have one topic left and then
we're finally wrapping up so you can all
go pass out on your beds i know it's a
long show i can just see it on alex's
face
my dogs is going crazy now i love it i'm
gonna put my dog out in the backyard
hold on i'm good i'm good to go also
somebody asked me i have i yes you can
go use the bathroom you do not need to
ask me you're allowed to use the
bathroom
um
oh dusty you can go use the bathroom
permanently if you appreciate it
wait can i really yes
okay don't don't leave destiny we got it
last round we got to finish it we
finished what we started here okay so
we're going to the last topic and the
last topic is a simple one
how do we unite the country now this
could also apply to countries that uh
like for example he's in hungary uh adam
is so currently i mean i mean germany so
well he's from hungary but he's in
germany uh but this is something that
can apply across the world because
divisions and and
across party lines and across people's
is international a phenomenon but how do
we unite the country uh
through an american perspective or an
australian perspective or any
perspective
how do we go about it
or is it a lost cause a very doomer
question i'm gonna start with taft in
the bottom right hand corner
um
how do we unite the country
i mean i think there's a serious problem
with people polarizing and sectioning
off into their own groups
and you see that on social media
especially
people develop echo chambers and
reinforce negative opinions i think that
we need to
try our best to reach out to people and
have conversations
and to connect with people even if we
think that they
if we disagree with them to an
incredible degree
this is this tends to be more of a
problem with progressives they're more
likely to ban or block someone
based on political problems political
disagreements than conservatives but it
goes both ways and the number
one thing that we need to be doing is
just
making sure people are talking to each
other more
wonderful now we're going to throw it
over to kevin
yeah thanks dylan
so to kind of answer this question there
are a lot of factors here but i think
you know uh we can look at some of the
micro factors of the division between
individuals and whatnot and what sort of
solutions might exist there and i
actually think that to some extent uh
debate culture has helped with that to
mitigate divisions i think you know
imagine if panels like this didn't exist
we'd actually be in a worse position so
i think that talking to the other side
is important debates are important and i
think that yeah there is a problem with
some people that don't really want to
engage in debate i've seen this
it used to traditionally be a problem
more attributable to progressives and
people left of that but that's changed
in recent years where what i've seen now
is actually uh oftentimes uh it'll be
people of like the stephen crowder type
for example that don't want to debate
they'll shy away from debating that's
always very cringy uh now at a broader
level more systemic level i think that
there is a there is a role for
government here to actually step into
to provide
a a mechanism for the the divisions that
do exist and there's always going to be
divisions in disagreement but to have
that be more organic because we know and
this is a fact that the divisions that
exist in our societies in canada uh
america australia the uk have been uh
exacerbated by foreign interference
particularly emanating from fascist
russia we have the research agency
internet research agency based in st
petersburg that have been uh co-opting
numerous progressive far left and far
right and alt-right groups and ping them
against each other because they know
they can't defeat us on a battlefield so
they have to stoop to these levels what
i would suggest the government do it's
very simple uh we ban russia today
there's no more hostile media that's
tolerated to propagandize our kids
basically and sometimes even our
grandparents get suckered into it and
there's no there's no more uh media
officials media figures social media
figures getting paid by hostile entities
and not registering that i think
registering foreign agents is important
and i think no you should not be allowed
to accept thousand dollar donation from
the syrian dictator jimmy dore so that's
how i would go about that
pixel
muted
i'm here
oops um i'll i'll explain from an
australian perspective i think there's a
lot of challenges when it comes to
uniting a country and i don't know if it
will ever be fully achieved in any of
our lifetimes um i think there are
certain things that we can do uh to
increase the robustness of uh democratic
uh structures
in uh our society i also think that
um i agree with the previous two
speakers that um talking uh to people
who disagree with you is really
important um
uh to be able to navigate some of the
more difficult issues i think why it's
such a problem in progressive spaces is
because for so long uh minorities who
generally lend towards progressive um
ideology have really struggled and felt
like they were fighting for their
identity um and so what has happened is
kind of a fragmentation of the left
which has resulted in kind of
uh an in
an in-group out group rhetoric that
exists on the left like if you're not my
type of left then
you're not on my team um and so i think
one of the best things we could possibly
do
is stop thinking about
politics and uh
political conversation as a team sport
rather just a large conversation
but in order to be able to do that there
are some fundamental things that people
need to agree on whether that is like
liberty or personal rights and things
like that so i don't know if it will
happen in our lifetime i think in
america you have a particular
uh
particularly large set of challenges
mainly because of the leaking of um
religion into
uh political discourse but i i don't
know we'll see
okay next i'm going to throw it over to
parker
um i think that a way in which we could
unite the country is by addressing bad
arguments that exist instead of just
banning them off platforms i also think
that talking about these issues and
educating people on each other's
opinions because people have a huge
misunderstanding of other people's
ideologies will allow us to understand
other people a lot more but one more
thing i do want to ask is what do we
consider like a united country like what
would a united country look like because
i don't think we'd be anywhere near like
what a united country would be like
associated with
okay now i'm gonna throw it over to
destiny
i think the two most important things
need to happen is one we need to have
some factual basis that we agree on
without that literally everything falls
to pieces and right now we like have
different groups of people that just
have totally different realities that
they live in in the united states um so
i think that's one of the most important
things uh second thing hopefully that
kind of stems from a result of that is
we need to go back to being able to
fight with each other rather than all of
us kind of existing in our own areas uh
it's getting scary how far the right and
the left are kind of like spreading
apart because there doesn't seem to be
much conversation anymore um i think the
polarization has gotten really extreme
such that everybody on the left sees
everyone right as a fascist everyone on
the right he's everybody on the left to
some weird sjw woke police and there's
like no more conversation in the middle
that kind of keeps both sides grounded
into themselves
and you just copied my take unbelievable
yeah but i bet i said it better [ __ ] you
maybe
okay i'll throw it now over to alex
stein how do we unite the country alex
are you that united figure
yeah of course i mean this would be very
easy to unite the country i mean first
things first if the dallas cowboys
winning the super bowl that would help
but um listen what we have to do is we
have to do a reallocation of the
military industrial complex and we'd
have to give our people universal basic
income because that would make everybody
happy i'm not even that pro-universal
basic income i'm just not pro wasting
all this money in the military
industrial complex so i'm talking about
what will actually unite the country and
we'll make people happy i'm not saying
this is the best thing and then once you
do that you'll give enough people
everybody can buy their pla their
playstation 5 and then they can plug
into the metaverse and that's what's
going to happen is they're going to make
our world so terrible on the outside
that we're going to run to the metaverse
and in the metaverse we can be 10 feet
tall we can have a 10-inch dick we can
be transsexual we can be a badass so the
way we unite the country is we got to
give enough people enough money to buy
technology in order to plug into mark
zuckerberg's metaverse and then that way
we wouldn't have time to fight because a
digital fight nobody gets hurt it's like
dungeon and dragons or something so
that's the only way we unite the country
is we take the fight off the street and
we bring it to the metaverse and in
there with the universal basic income we
live like kings when we plug into our
pod i can't wait for it what do you
think of the 49ers alex
i think though listen this is the
conspiracy side i i actually played high
school football with matt stafford who's
my quarterback i was captain of the team
but listen i believe that this is the
conspiracy this is the conspiracy that's
true you can look it up highland park
football captain alex 99 but this is the
conspiracy what they're going to say san
francisco is going to win
pittsburgh has six super bowls new
england patriots have six super bowls
and now san francisco is going to get
their sixth super bowl six six six so if
they win it got called here tonight you
heard it here first
throw it over to christian
yeah well you know
i think a lot of people have hit on a
good point here by saying conversation
is important but more than conversation
the foundational basis upon which we
pursue conversation for is even more
important the philosopher hugo groces
who many folks haven't heard of but the
american founder certainly knew who he
was and john locke's certainly knew he
was because john locke took a lot of
influence from him he said that
man along with being a social creature
which wasn't really unique or new to him
he said that along being a social
creature man's existence also is
interested in a peaceable relation with
other people so while we are a social
creature it doesn't just mean we can
talk or anything it means we also want
to build civilization community society
there is a natural interest for us to
want to do this but in order for us to
do this kind of thing
we have to recognize this is the point
that he makes others make as well that
there has to be a self-love that we have
for ourselves because in order to build
something with other people we have to
love and respect ourselves the problem
is a problem of resentment and in
politics these days politics is
oftentimes a game of resentment a lot of
people hate they hate they hate they
hate and they hate so much they forget
how to love so i do think in a sense
that love of self at least is the basis
for how we can continue you know even
having a common basis because we cannot
we can disagree on every single other
thing but if we can agree on you know
what we love ourselves enough to work
together in concert to achieve some
common name if we don't even we don't
know what it is
then that'll be enough i think to save
civilization um so conversation is
important but self-love is also
important and increasing that amount of
self-love in the conversation is also
equally important wow
destiny do you love everyone on this
panel
yeah
i have no reason not to love me the
murderer destiny right
that's the thing we can do thank you
guys
we can viciously and angrily disagree
with each other back in the day walk
away saying hopefully saying this is a
good faith conversation i hope to have
more that self-love transposed into
universal love of community amazing
we're going to throw it now over to adam
to wrap up the intros for the final
topic
sure so unity in america well uh right
as others have said the problem is that
ps these two sides have uh diverged too
far from each other uh however i don't
think this pro this can be solved with
self love you know uh yeah we can all
like in this panel we're all we're all
uh cordial we're all intellectual we're
all you know black to each other but
what if i what but what if i was some
kind of groper you know and i said to
christian hey christian
as soon as we get into power we're going
to deport you back to africa and we
don't give a [ __ ] so you know goodbye so
at that point there can be like you know
as you can see there are certain limits
beyond which there's just no no
cooperation
and just there's there's no real way of
like coming together as a nation right i
think america is pretty close to that
point actually but this is this is oh
god this is due to so many reasons one
of which is
uh american media like america doesn't
have a state media like mostly impartial
state media like the bbc like uh czech
television like
established european
broadcasters which are for the most part
try to be impartial uh instead there is
uh for-profit uh news organizations and
of course i mean cnn msnbc et cetera
there's some like npc whatever
virtue signal et cetera for profit uh
kind of use organizations but then
there's fox news which is that
plus they have plus with the cause like
uh
rupert murdoch
is the owner or is the i believe the
chairman currently uh
there's in america i see a
mostly like on the right wing this like
very
sometimes well organized
essentially disinfo networks on par with
with rt so uh we had now we have the
[ __ ] breakdown over over uh uh mini
mini i think you know the disney's
minnie mouse having the
suit thingy instead of the skirt now we
have like
in america there's all these
uh
made like sort of manufactured outrages
uh and sometimes these manufactured
outrages actually go a bit beyond uh you
know minnie mouse and stuff sometimes
it's stuck across on making uh thinly
well the white supremacist uh
statements uh on air so and i don't see
this slowing down uh you know
uh we we've even gone so far in america
as uh january 6 for example
uh
so i i have no idea at this point how
how america could be united maybe with
time some people will grow out of it and
or like one solution i can see is that
conservatives like right-wing people in
general
uh
who vote republican et cetera they will
slowly fade into irrelevance and then
the democratic party will keep winning
the elections and then the real
presidential election becomes the
democratic primary and with that at
least you have the you have the the the
the uh the sort of right wing part of
the country contained
and so the so the differences will
become somewhat irrelevant
okay now uh who wants to start off the
open panel
okay
question once again
you know adam's something i think that
like yellow taps
yeah the rhetoric around like well we
just need to wait for
republicans and conservatives to fade
into irrelevance or contain them in some
way and then everything will be okay
i i think that that's the sort of thing
that like contributes to division and
frustration
uh between people and
i mean you're right that like
the united states is not going to be
united by any like easy means but
i think that we have to start by
accepting that there's going to be
fundamental differences in opinions
between people
and it's not enough to just wait for
them to disappear or hope they do but we
have to actually go to the table and
negotiate with them
the problem is once you get to the table
one one person says that oh yeah by the
way it looks looked like a fair election
by the one and the other thing is like
you know deep state pizzagate you know
the raping children it's uh on in the
basement so
at which point there's no there's no
real point
to discuss these things right so uh what
about when i say waiting for
conservatives to fade into irrelevance
i'm referring to a broader
uh societal tendency in the us which saw
like which sees like people with
progressive views increasing
and the only the only reason why
republicans are able to win presidential
elections at this point is due to uh
republican affirmative action aka uh the
electoral college
uh if you look at the the uh the voter
the electoral numbers like the the
popular vote numbers for like i think a
good 20 years except i think except for
bush
uh after 9 11 et cetera like there were
either the the the candidates for
republicans either won very narrowly or
just lost the popular vote donald trump
firebrand new age etc
future of the party lost to hillary
[ __ ] clinton uh by i think it was
like two million votes or something so
within the u.s there's a definite
tendency to for the country to move to
become more progressive and therefore
not align itself with republicans
and you know once like if if if only
like say 25 of the country is you know
deep state january 6th uh pizzagate
conservative then at that point there's
no real division because it's i mean
it's just the craziest i mean we have
them everywhere like seventy-five
percent i have to say one thing i just
say one thing you say pizzagate's crazy
i just say this one thing but you know
elaine maxwell just got convicted of
being a child sex procurer who would
float into the airplane so you know that
so you don't believe there's any child
so so i'm just i'm just saying you don't
believe there's any sort of child sex
exploitation i know you're talking about
it
even though maxwell is guilty of being a
child sex procurer no that nobody in
high up does anything with children is
that what you're saying adam that's not
relevant to the pizzagate though right
pizzagate that is
pizza but he's trying to he's trying to
generalize
anything else no but let me ask them a
question though and if you ask a
question right you've got a letter okay
can i can i clarify quickly yeah let me
clarify my question and then you answer
it but you ask them a question no okay
so wait okay so the point the point i
was making was not about was not about
the american political lead of course i
mean it's full of pedophiles as we've
seen like [ __ ] uh uh epson had the
phone numbers to have they have the
[ __ ] uh u.s elite sure that's why
that's why he was killed in prison
obviously like we we know that what i'm
saying but i'm i'm not talking about
okay i'm not
look i'm not talking about okay now
we're yeah sure so
but what i'm talking about is the people
and people's
views that have been heavily informed by
conservative media outlets i'm talking
about the american conservatives and
which we just essentially sent them off
the deep end so we're not talking about
the
decision makers per se we're talking
about people and their sentiments
i think conservatives and liberals both
know elaine maxwell uh can we tell her
i've got it
let's be for real
nobody here is prepared to have the deep
detailed conversation about pizzagate
except for maybe alex and so let's
probably bring it back to the main
conversation about it yeah okay
and i'm gonna i'm gonna start writing
down names i'm gonna start with
destiny then kevin then christian in
that order and then pixel um i think
that what taft said it has to be
reckoned with um this idea that
republicans are only here like i think
that democrats have been slowly forced
to accept that it is not the case that
republicans only exist in the united
states through some trickery of the
system as we expand voting to more
people even mail-in voting it doesn't
seem to favor one party over the other
as voting rights are expanded in states
it doesn't seem to favor one party over
the other and even the idea that like oh
my god things are unfairly gerrymandered
what a fair gerrymander even is is
highly contentious arguably the most
reasonable gerrymanders that represent
real districts in the united states
would heavily skew towards favoring
republicans because they tend to live in
more
diverse areas not diverse areas more
politically diverse areas than liberals
who are highly concentrated in cities so
i think we have to be careful not to
just assume that like we eliminated one
thing like it would be uh democrats
would uh get way more uh representation
something even the electoral college it
might be the case that republicans would
spend more time campaigning in like
central california or rural parts of
vermont or something if they knew that
they could get votes from there so even
the electoral college getting rid of
that might not necessarily change the
way the elections go we they might it
might not we don't know um i think it's
important that we recognize that we have
a true diversity of opinion in the
united states and that we do need to
reckon with the fact that there are a
lot of people disagree with each other
and then work to like bridge that gap
and have those conversations
when everyone's in their echo chambers
right that's what causes this
misinformation to spread and these
conspiracy theories to thrive it's when
people feel totally dismissed out of
hand they say well [ __ ] you i'm not
going to talk to you anymore i'm only
going to talk to people who are going to
legitimize my views right and that's
scary that's dangerous we can't have a
thriving functional society
based on people feeling this way so
again i think that you know really we
need to reckon with actual actual
differences and bring people to the
table to talk to them
so conservatives and republicans are
always going to be a thing i've argued
before
that the culture war is obviously that's
not up for debate eventually even the
most conservative republicans will
support trans rights in a couple hundred
years but
conservatives will still be a thing
they'll still be more conservative than
where progressives are and the
republican party will still be a thing
or at least the the similar ideology to
it because those values those uh
economic beliefs especially are popular
and do resonate with people and the
democrats don't offer that in fact i
would say that it's actually kind of the
opposite of what adam was getting at
right now which is that if the
republicans were to just drop like not
everybody who's a republican does this
but a lot of republican officials will
race bait they'll do dog whistles
against latinos and blacks if they drop
that and they genuinely were like an
equal opportunity type party they didn't
have that sort of like white centric
bias to them i would argue they would
basically turn america into an a
one-party democracy you'd still have the
democratic party they look a lot like
japan but the republicans would win
every election because a lot of black
voters a lot of latino voters are
actually conservative and so the only
reason why the democrats have a serious
shot each election is that the
republicans shoot themselves in the foot
by by being racist you might say well
why do they do it well they don't
necessarily care about winning they they
a lot of these officials would rather
not have to sit or work with a black guy
than win more elections and that's just
the nature of the party right now now
that's not to say all republicans i
think bill crystal if you look at him
he's got a great way to unite and have a
really reasonable republican party uh
and in fact i would say you know people
like bill crystal people like mitt
romney these are the sort of folks on
the right
that the left should be engaging with
should be welcoming not demonizing or
whatever because they fundamentally do
believe in a any
a in a generally a progressive america
in the sense of you know racial equality
and everything they just happen to be
you know conservative on matters of
economics and whatnot or you know small
liberal that sort of stuff i think the
problem is you know
you've got a radical fringe on the far
right in the far left and they've been
heightened and amplified by foreign
interference specifically always having
them on you turn on russia today america
who's always on it's the green party
it's a libertarian party it's some
far-right racist that's some far-left
pro-russia fan right that's what's
really driving that division because
america's always had division it was
just never as salient as it is now
because there's that potential for
foreign walker is next
walker sorry watson
that's funny um no i must i want to echo
what taft and destiny said you know
conversation is important and as
something really has a very cynical and
dismal view of civilization you know jon
stewart mill had the radical idea that
con that discourse was the bridge
between error and truth and really the
reason again why a lot of people embrace
falsehood is because human beings are
creatures of desire we desire
uh something a little bit bigger than
ourselves we desire community and a lot
of folks happen to just fall into the
wrong kind of people who say the right
kind of things or what's selling the
right kind of things to them and soothe
their ears and that brings them down
this long tailspin this is how cults
happen this is how the kukas klan has
got a lot of its members even in and
daryl davis has used the principle of
discourse to go ahead and convince many
klansmen to shed the robe and embrace a
colorblind idea and forego their racism
so discussion is absolutely imperative
to beating bad ideas i mean sectioning
off an entire part of the country like
hillary clinton did calling them
deplorables or undesirables doesn't do
anything but cause more resentment and
cause bad ideas to flourish even more so
we have to confront this with discourse
not with derision
pixel
um i think
the problem in america is that because
discourse has always been so far to the
right
as opposed to in other
let's say liberal democracies it's that
a lot of progressives have commonly had
to meet conservatives on
their truth on their common ground like
the agreement in a christian god or
like
progressives in america have always had
to continue to make concessions um to
conservative beliefs in order to be able
to continue having that conversation
with them and that's the most difficult
thing um to get past in american
politics because um there are just
fundamental differences in like an
understanding of the world um and so i
think that is where one of the major
struggles will exist in uniting uh if
we're talking about conversation that's
where one of the like fundamental
problems will be
and adam
sure so i just wanted to add to what i
said before um so as pixel said the us
is distinctly more sort of right-leaning
uh than other uh western democracies
that's that's just true the democratic
party is from europe it's like it's like
a center-right party at best with some
like progressive virtue signaling which
is good though like and some progressive
measures so that's good
um the problem the problem with the
republican party though is that the far
right has kind of started becoming the
mainstream under trump you know like
trump dropping the euphemism instead of
instead of protecting the job market now
we have yeah we're just gonna bar
mexicans and like muslims and whatever
from the country uh you know the
of course the classic very fine people
on both sides
so on the republican party there has
been a distinct shift towards the far
right in recent years
and
at that point like that's i think that's
the thing that really prevents discourse
because
okay it's like so so uh so it was like
this is the centrism problem right so if
one party says
if one party says hey we want to let in
say one million immigrants into the us
every year and the other party says okay
well we want to let in uh 200 000
immigrants uh to the us every year and
so you know we can come to we can sit
down sit down to the table we can
discuss we can come to a conclusion okay
you know what we're gonna let in six
hundred thousand immigrants and everyone
is happy everyone's celebrating
but then what if one party says hey we
should let in immigrants into the
country and the other says
that uh no we cannot do that because
that will ruin the white character of
our nation and so ban all immigration is
from brown countries etc like there's
there's no argument to be had there
right because the views are just
diametrically diametrically opposed and
so what you can do there is essentially
work to make the other side which you
find heinous
essentially irrelevant
politically uh which which is a it's a
it's a natural process so don't think of
this as like the the biden death squad
showing up to alabama and like purging
the trailer parks or something no this
is this is just an ongoing process and i
think every person who is not who
doesn't belong to the republican school
of thought i think should help it along
and i have a cat on my chair thank you
why not ask people why they believe the
things they believe and then use
scrutiny to analyze those beliefs yes
there are some people who are indeed way
far gone i agree and how society or how
whether us as individuals not society as
individuals handle those kind of folks
is going to be a very different
conversation but a lot of folks are
quite agreeable at least on some basic
things and so you shouldn't just count
off a bunch of people right off a bunch
of people rather from you know being
reasoned with because they hold some
beliefs that you personally find to be
heinous or incorrect again this is the
darrell davis principle going to like to
like the dens of the clansmen show them
kindness talk to them explain to them
nicely why they're wrong and if many of
some of them will not shed their beliefs
but many of them did and are continuing
to do so and they're leaving that
ideology and colorblindness and you know
racial equality are getting more
advocates which makes the ideas that you
want to see succeed even more popular
that's the principle we should be
embracing you know and so this idea that
people who are again deplorables they're
far gone that's just not an idea that's
going to be contributive to a free and
prospering civilization it's contributed
to an insular civilization that is going
to eventually evolve into some kind of
internal conflict and perhaps collapse
from it or whatever well christian
the problem with that though is that
when hillary clinton said that there was
50 she said about half of trump
supporters were deplorable she was
correct about that and that those people
in recent years have gotten far more
radicalized to the point where one
america news network is the liberal wing
of their movement that's how that's how
like it's a problem okay and i think you
know any sort of serious discussion
about this can't just be okay well let's
just sit down and talk to people on the
other side we actually have to look at
what's the source of the problem because
there was always division in america but
social media and the internet allowed
foreign countries foreign enemies to
take advantage of that and we can't do
that to russia because russia censors
their own media russia meddles in their
own media they have their own state
media so they can do it to us but we
can't do it to them now i'm not arguing
we should be like them but it is a
vulnerability of an open society and a
democracy and i think that we need to be
aware of it and we should have
legislation to keep out media propaganda
from hostile countries would you be
opposed to that
yeah because again the internet has sort
of democratized and connected the entire
world together and so you know even if
you explicitly ban foreign regimes from
advertising in america there are other
ways that foreign regimes get their
stuff into america so instead of trying
to ban instead of trying to ban and
censor things why not i wouldn't even be
opposed to and this is a little bit even
too much for me so the government
released releasing some sort of national
security notice that's like a handbook
here's how you can recognize the signs
of foreign influence in certain certain
kinds of ads i wouldn't be opposed to
that because yes it can be a national
security problem in some cases but
banning and censoring things will not
stop a regime that is aggressively
determined on influencing american minds
from doing so
slow them down considerably
you're fine with the government you're
fine wait wait you're fighting you're
fine with the government acknowledging
that it's a security threat but you're
not okay with the government addressing
that threat you just say leave people to
their own devices because that's not
working putin's winning the information
war right now and it's unfortunate the
founders understood that you need a
virtuous people for a free society and
you cannot
warfare the way that he's doing right
the point is much less about the
founders and more so about the principle
of how of people being self-educated and
having the knowledge to combat these
things themselves because that's going
to be much more powerful in my opinion
education is the problem though right
like because the american education
system is so flawed in so many ways yes
the self self education system is not
working because you literally have q
anon which got exported to like my
country as well and everywhere
why is everybody saying the right joe
joe biden just got 81 million votes and
is our president why are you guys keep
on talking that everybody's so right in
america i would say that america is more
progressive than right i mean
81 million they're so more people are
progressive so trump lost do you know
that but that's still a lot of people
that means less
i can't hear anything so we gotta
everybody quiet down for a second alex
sign hasn't said anything for most of
the panel so i'm gonna let him i haven't
ever i can't get a word in i mean kevin
all he does is i mean talk about cringe
dude every point you make is cringe i
mean i can't even listen to you
that doesn't mean i can't have an
opinion and that doesn't mean every
opinion that i make is your opinion
so your opinion
you're not goofy you're sitting there
with a bmi like a dude you're sitting
there with that beard you look like the
worst goofball i've ever seen in my life
you're in canada you don't even know
what you're talking about you're talking
about the representation of america you
don't every time you think
okay
okay both of you are gonna be meeting
okay alex so you
uh will be able to finish your point you
got about like 30 seconds okay all right
i mean i'm just saying if that if you
have any viewers they're they're
absolutely idiots i'm just i just want
to say that
okay well i'm just saying they're absurd
so you can say whatever you want about
me but listen this is the problem with
america is that we have a media that's
going to constantly keep us divided
every single aspect from the social
engineering from the people in power is
going to keep us divided so listen and
really in a foxhole people aren't even
that racist when you go into the store
people aren't like saying the n word
it's not as bad as you say there's not
people having lynchings yes does racism
exist of course but to the level and
degree that they say racism exists it's
not like that but you're going to have
people this is the thing this is a
problem a w hamburgers when they got in
the hamburger business they were trying
to compete with mcdonald's they did a
nationwide survey study they asked
americans what they thought was a better
value a quarter pounder burger for four
dollars or a third pound burger for the
same price overwhelmingly americans pick
the quarter pounder burger thinking
one-fourth is more than one-third so
we're dealing with idiots everybody
can't do a simple math problem like that
so that's why the media that's why the
social engineers that control the
narrative will always have us fighting
with each other if we actually want to
solve our problems we would stop
fighting and stop fighting with each
other bickering over rest set race sex
and gender issues that people don't even
normally care about and actually fix the
the multinational corporations that are
ruining the world yeah i'm saying but
that's how we that's how we solve the
problems that's how we do people care
about race and sex and gender that's
kind of a big part of people's lives
dude
but i'm saying at the store
people
that's what i'm saying you shouldn't
judge a person by the color of their
skin you should judge it by the content
of their character but you don't want to
do that you have to give you on the side
you have to make everything about
intersectionality i'm the one that's
trying to
that do have an issue with people on the
basis of their skin color and their
children don't have a problem with
anybody
i'm saying the conspiracy camp the the
far-right conspiracy camp that's
basically all right
i'm not all right okay you're putting me
you're trying to make medicine
because what you're doing right now both
of you is you're dividing this country
further okay you're tearing it at the
seams you and kevin will divide this
country further uh the the vac song man
and the canadian so
um we're probably going to wrap it up
since we're 11 12. uh so i'm going to
start with christian because christian
wants to say something
yeah i i think that this is uh this is a
problem across political spectrum too i
think that a lot of progressives have
tend to overstate the influence of q
anon a lot of the fringer groups in the
trump camp uh lo and behold the trump
camp most certainly has brought out some
elements of the country that are horrid
and that should not at all be embraced
at all and that means we shouldn't talk
to them but they're just some elements
that are just have bad beliefs but most
people i think who voted for trump voted
as a protest statement against the
establishment that the typical everyday
establishment you know doings of
washington you know mitch mcconnell's
saying we're going to balance the budget
going ahead and passing a one trillion
dollar omnibus bill you know john
boehner saying we're going to cut cap
and balance and going ahead and finding
one of the and and and funding some of
barack obama's one of the biggest
spending expenses i mean there are all
kind of reasons why trump was voted in
and to say that racism was one of them
uh is really to oversafe the importance
of that and really i think conservatives
overstate the amount of socialists on
the left a lot of folks on the left
really aren't socialist a lot of books
on the left are basically progressive
some are neoliberals or whatever some of
them don't think loopers on the left i
think they are um but a lot of them are
not you know strict socialists so i
think that the fundamental attribution
error is a psychological phenomenon
hasn't impacted all of us but ultimately
to wrap this all up i think that again
that we have a we have a basis within
our humanity for civilizational unity uh
and i think that if we challenge channel
that basis if we use self-love as a
general rule not because obviously not
everyone is going to adhere that
principle but if we use self-love as a
way to enter to interact with the
community and as a way to respect others
we can get past our political
differences insofar as we can allow we
can sustain a civilization
uh and still
argue honestly and earnestly like we've
done tonight so i appreciate it guys
this has been a wonderful conversation
wonderful and where can people find you
oh yeah so you can find me on oh i'm
scared for this one because this is i've
been saying some crazy stuff tonight i
guess you can find me on twitter or at
official c watson or you can find me on
youtube my youtube channel is christian
watson you just type in it on youtube
it's christian watson w-a-t-s-o-n and uh
you can go to
christianjwatson.com and uh email me if
you want to and uh yeah i look forward
interacting with the folks who um who
i've been speaking to tonight
wonderful happy to have you on turn it
over now to adam something
thank you so it's been a very good
discussion um so uh should we refer to
the topics we've discussed or should we
just like do generally just the last
topic and then outro
all right sure so yeah um
basically
the fact that americans call everything
and anything
left of center socialism and communism
is also a product largely of the uh sort
of this fox news writing media empire
etc as we all know socialism equal
government does thing uh
oh well um
anyway america but the american left is
like like a military sagadam at best
europe has four more left-leaning uh
political candidates so i don't think
this is such a such a big issue like the
leftism in america which almost doesn't
exist
uh otherwise like chris you said you
were you're worried about civilization
or decline and uh going insular and
isolationism et cetera well that
typically happens when people like the
like in the trump camp get elected of
when they start
excluding people when isolationism gets
frustrated up uh that's usually the sign
of of course patriotic education you
know there's nothing wrong with the
country don't even
uh try to fix it all those progressives
who want change in the country are
enemies uh like that's usually
it's it's a it's a very there's a very
good correlation with like nations dying
with those uh
when those sentiments get too popular or
too loud
otherwise
that's my two cents on the issue thank
you for having me on it's been fun i'm
on youtube uh don't worry you'll find me
so
happy to have you on and you're
basically only on youtube you don't have
like a twitter you don't have like
anything
i'm very concerned about my own mental
health yes
wonderful now we're going to throw it to
alex stein
well unfortunately i don't have any uh
caution about my mental health so uh
that's the difference between you and me
uh my mental health is uh level insanity
but listen guys uh like i said earlier
oh you can find me on youtube conspiracy
castle or twitter alex99 listen listen
uh kevin i i don't dislike you you know
i know we argued about stuff but when
you say cringe every single second
that's a lot of self-projection but let
me do a little cringe myself for this
debate i'm a conspiracy tour i'm a
conspiratorial person but that doesn't
mean i'm on the right side i think that
insulin costs 200 in texas but it's two
dollars in mexico that's wrong we should
have some sort of socialized medicine so
the problem is you guys are
marginalizing people by saying oh
because
i don't like trump what i'm saying is is
you guys are you know putting people you
guys are marginalized people by saying
people on the right are all trump
supporters you're putting people so
really that is racist what you're doing
when you do that and the way you judge
like that i'm just saying it is it is so
so at the end of the day
i mean when you guys jud when you guys
judge a country based on those those
those things you are doing the exact
same thing that you're trying to speak
against so a lot of hypocrites a lot of
people i enjoyed in this debate a lot of
people hopefully i'll get to talk to you
again but at the end of the day uh we
really don't hate each other we're
divided by uh you know social engineers
that make us hate each other and really
most people will help somebody at the
end on the side of the road if they're
broken down at least in my neighborhood
they will go get you a tank of gas i
mean that's just that's just how the
america that i live in is honestly
wonderful and i'm gonna now throw it
over to parker
uh so i think there are a lot of ideas
that we do need to address like for
example q1 on and anti-vax a lot of the
times people will like to just say that
like oh they're crazy and not
necessarily addressed their arguments i
know there's a lot of like actual
like basis to that a lot of them are but
we do also need to recognize that there
are lots of people out there
specifically vaccine hesitant people who
are becoming susceptible to these types
of arguments because their narratives
are being banned and not talked about
instead of just banning and not talking
about them we should address these
arguments so that people aren't
necessarily um
emboldened like those ideas aren't
emboldened um i am on tick talk i go
live every single day relatively uh
my is at parker sedgwick it was great
having a conversation today i'm happy to
have come on and thanks for the
opportunity
happy to have you here hope to have you
again in the future now we're gonna
throw it over to pixel's mixel
um i think at the end of the day
conversation is good but there is a lot
of nuance that needs to be navigated um
which sometimes gets lost on the
internet um
i think that anything we can do uh to
make a democracy more robust is really
important uh
including addressing things in america
such as the electoral electoral
college and
um media
influencers someone who lives in
australia and has seen a lot of american
influence over the pandemic it's
uh
important to me uh to at least see
where america goes because it really
does it has deep influence um
all throughout the west um when it you
know in my case in particular uh my
state leader was called a communist for
trying to uh save people from the
pandemic so um
it's
an interesting time to be having these
conversations but i'll keep having them
i am on very late at night american time
i cover the news i have a decent uh bbc
news reader voice that i do use to cover
the news there's a bit of a shtick and
then we talk about it so
yeah i'm not i'm not afraid of differing
opinions i sometimes muddle my words
because my brain goes too fast and then
it comes out bad but yeah
um twitch.tv slash pixel snixel
happy to have you all i'm dylan i
appreciate it happy to have you throwing
it over now to kevin
castle
yeah thanks dylan it's great to be here
tonight we had some pretty heated
discussions and debates that was pretty
good so i will close by saying you know
i think it's important to note that yeah
the problem with the division in the
united states and western countries is
not just coming from the far right i i
think i made very clear to mention it's
also a problem with the far left and
populism in general and any conversation
that that's going to address this to
actually seek meaningful solutions has
to ultimately focus on how do we counter
and prevent and minimize and mitigate
foreign interference because that really
is the big factor that changed between
standard division for centuries versus
now is that now countries can meddle a
lot easier via the internet and we have
been asleep to it it's time to wake up
we got two cold wars going on right now
our enemies know it it's time that we
woke up to it and we had our sputnik
moments and we actually got serious
about countering the enemies of freedom
and liberalism so i'm kevin casley i
host superpower broadcasting we stream
to twitch uh seven days a week and also
uh upload content to youtube daily as
well and gonna have some premieres over
there again uh coming up in the near
future we also do gaming streams now and
then but mostly talk about foreign
policy and whatnot uh if you want to
follow me on twitter i'm on twitter at
kevin castle and i'm going to be doing a
post show on superpower broadcasting to
talk about this uh panel tonight in
about half an hour over uh on twitch
superpower broadcasting thanks dylan
sorry i just hear some howling in the
background uh throwing it over to taft
yeah great um
i would say i grew up in a rural
community and around a lot of
conservatives and i think that one thing
that progressives and leftists need to
know
is that when you're telling people that
they're like these uninformed like idiot
racist people who believe in all these
conspiracy theories
you're not helping the conversation
you're not advancing it because what
people are going to do is they're going
to look at you and say well i don't
believe in q anon right like or i guess
i know someone who believes in q anon
but like i don't believe in it or
they're going to say i don't feel racist
because i don't judge people by the
color of their skin right and in their
mind even if you believe that like
having
a you know black supreme court justice
is like fighting racism in their mind
they're going to think well no that is
racist because what we need is actually
colorblindness and that's what it means
to be non-racist
so i think that if you really want
political unity you need to meet these
people on their terms and that means not
just like totally demonizing them even
if you think that they're totally wrong
so
i i mean i think that there just needs
to be a lot more open dialogue and
communication from people
i would say thanks for thanks for the
conversation it was definitely fun uh
these are definitely hard hard debates
to get a word in edgewise or
to express nuanced complicated ideas
but i had a good time follow me at taft
wonderful happy to have you on and
destiny
definitely wouldn't predict at the
beginning of the night that conspiracy
cast would be the far and away most
impressive debater on the panel but i
mean man he made some pretty killer
points he was able to point out some uh
big flaws in other people's arguments so
yeah i guess you can learn new things on
these panels all the time without ever
realizing it i'm glad i'm here it's fun
uh fun exchange of ideas uh and that's
what america needs to truly heal is more
people
talking about how everybody is a
pedophile while also understanding that
insulin is too high outstanding destiny
disney are you how are you doing tonight
i'm doing fine but i have to go to the
gym and i'm already like an hour late
what do you want well yeah wait before
you get weird personal stuff are we done
with the show we mean weird personal
[ __ ] right the fact look here's i just
look i got my camera up high so you're
looking down at me black and white so
i'm non-threatening i just want to know
why the [ __ ] you keep ducking me right
not liking anything bro you're [ __ ]
me harder than my sister in a [ __ ]
hoedown all right
look all i know is that somehow you and
dylan end up [ __ ] meeting right and
then he ends up sick with kobe right and
then the match gets [ __ ] pushed out
further and further and further when he
gonna stop ducking me bro that's all i
want to know so with that you can go
back you need to go to the [ __ ] gym
make sure you pump out some extra
[ __ ] weight because i'm coming for
that ass ctv out
wow
wow honestly
it seems that wow what was that all
about i got your bag destiny almost i'm
gonna send him a computer virus dude
what is that guys yeah
castle thank you wow it seems that the
ctv
uh destiny match is heating up as they
continue to have beef nest if you have
any thoughts on that he's calling you
out yeah i need to go ahead and hurry up
to the gym so that i can work on get
strong for him to okay good see you all
later buddy
[Music]
[Music]
you